3am and the facility is quiet office
workers and administrators roam the
Halls security officers stand at their
posts clad in advance tactical armor and
carrying standard issue M4 carbines
three Foundation employees sit at
flickering monitors watching a live feed
of footage from the containment cell of
the infamous scp-106 or as it's referred
to by all staff the old man no
Foundation Personnel are permitted to
travel within 60 feet of the cell for
security reasons and nobody is permitted
to physically interact with the anomaly
without the approval of two-thirds of o5
command the observer's eyes itch and
Sting from hours of unending blue light
exposure but they can't look away the
old man is Crafty he might have the
insatiable bloodlust of a hungry great
white shark but he's not mindless he's a
calculating Predator more sadistic than
the worst human serial killer and he's
always searching for the next
opportunity according to the foundation
records he's been active since at least
World War II and it's estimated that he
has hundreds if not thousands of victims
to his name and many of those made
simple but extremely foolish mistakes of
underestimating him after all it only
takes a few seconds of inattentiveness
and the briefest moment of distraction
to give him the window he needs to do
what you ask oh don't worry you'll find
out just like they did the old man has
his nickname for a reason most of the
time he really does look exactly like
that an old man or more specifically an
old man's decaying corpse his body
covered in Rotten Dark grayish black
flesh that looks like putrid meat though
the creature has been observed being
able to change shape the rod seems to
run too deep for the old man to ever
hide it Foundation employees that have
observed scp-106 for extended periods of
time have reported seeing it assume the
form of grinning decayed children and
women whose rotted flesh barely hangs on
their creaking bones just seeing the
images through a video feed is enough to
cause a lifetime of insomnia and other
sleeping issues still they have a job to
do and the cameras remain fixed on the
old man he's been completely motionless
for three months just sitting there like
a a Buddhist monk in deep meditation a
novice might see this period of
inactivity as a cause for celebration
but those with experience know that this
is merely the Calm before the storm
scp-106 can remain in a dormant state
for months at a time described by the
foundation scientist as a lulling state
it's believed that the Old Man simply
waiting for its captors to get soft make
a mistake or simply have a momentary
lapse in concentration which is all it
needs to make its move it had happened
so many times before and it was about to
happen again one of The Observers must
have felt an overwhelming wave of
anxiety as he saw the creature ever so
slightly twitch just a tiny quiver in
the shoulder muscles but that was enough
to tell the Observer that their day had
just taken a terrifying turn he grabbed
the emergency phone fixed to his desk
and practically screamed into the
receiver that 106 is moving that they
need a Tactical Team stat but it was
already too late he and the other two
observers stared into the monitors with
their mouths Agape as a gooey rust-like
substance began to pool around the
creature on the floor of its cell slowly
creature creaned its withered neck
around its face was fixed into a broad
yellow tooth lipless Grim its eyes had
the kind of dull flat malice of an
underwater Predator it looked directly
into the camera directly at them and
smiled The Observers knew this was bad
really really bad with what they could
have sworn was a little nod the old man
began sinking into the rusty puddle it
made on the ground beneath it until it
had disappeared entirely scp-106 is
capable of phasing through any solid
surface with ease making it one of the
hardest entities to reliably contain and
earning it a spot on the dreaded keter
class reserved for the anomalies that
are complete nightmares to keep locked
up through the years of costly research
and deadly trial and error the
foundation would later devise ways of at
least slowing the creature down it's
shown to have an aversion to lead highly
complex or random physical structures
and intense bright light none of these
cause harm to the creature as far as we
know literally nothing can but they'll
at least buy you some precious extra
seconds with which to at least least try
and Escape seconds the three observers
didn't have one of them grabbed an
emergency line again and barked into it
that they lost visual on the anomaly
just then The Observers heard a faint
crackling sound behind them and the
hissing of a chemical burn they turned
in horror to see a huge Rusty burn mark
expanding across the wall right next to
the door which was their only Escape
Route they backed as far away from the
door as they could as a rotten hand
began reaching out of the mass of
corrosive black sludge followed by the
grinning face of scp-106 ready to have
some fun meanwhile two heavily armed
security officers agents Goodwin and
Resnick came charging down the corridor
toward the observation rooms it become a
bleak slogan during scp-106 Escape
attempts that all you need to do is
follow the screams and that motto was
proven true that night because awful
things were happening to the observation
Personnel they were certainly screaming
about it of course even with the top of
the line firearms there was little they
could do to harm the rampaging old man
he seemed immune to all forms of
physical damage all they could hope to
do was keep the thing distracted until
the scientists and containment
Specialists finish the preparations to
lure him back into his containment cell
Goodwin surged forward while Resnick
covered his six vigilance was key as
unlike a standard human combatant
scp-106 could attack from literally any
angle including above or below physical
obstacles were irrelevant to him and no
cover was safe the hardened security
officers could see the burn mark on the
wall of the observation room as they
approached scp-106 was perpetually
coated in a thick black mucus with
powerful corrosive properties that left
any surfaces it touched permanently
marked Foundation scientists speculated
that this mucus served as a kind of
pre-digestive substance that tenderizes
meat and Bone alike but to what purpose
this serves as a mystery as the old man
has never been observed eating it's
postulated that the only purpose is
causing additional pain Goodwin in
Resnick knew to treat this hissing
sludge as a Potential Threat as the
corrosive properties would remain active
for as much as six hours before finally
fizzling out the two officers shared a
quiet nod before Goodwin breached the
observation room door with a hard kick
the two of them searched inside guns at
the ready in their time working at the
foundation they'd seen some truly
horrific sites from the mutilation of
d-class personnel typically death row
prison inmates brought in for use as SCP
guinea pigs to the violence and Mayhem
of a containment bridge but there was
nothing in their past that would ever
make the horrifying sight they saw in
the observation room that night feel
normal all three observers were dead
almost nothing remained of two of them
and the third while still intact no
longer looked human he looked like he'd
somehow been dead a hundred years in the
brief period that the old man had been
free his skin was gray and completely
dried out and its mouth was locked into
a Perpetual scream it was a massacre but
there was no sign of the old man Goodwin
grabbed his radio and whispered this is
Goodwin in observation room 6 requesting
immediate backup we have no idea where
this thing but his sentence was cut off
by a sudden scream from agent Resnick
SCP Foundation security officers are as
tough as Nails the best of the best you
might say recruited from the top
military organizations in the world so
hearing one of them scream in Fright is
a rare if not impossible occurrence but
even they were forced to yell out in
fear when they looked up to see the old
man standing on the ceiling grinning
down at them Resnick raised his M4 and
shot a three-round burst at Center Mass
scp-106 didn't care even under sustained
gunfire from the two security officers
it didn't glitch The Old Man simply
reached down and snatched agent Resnick
from the ground like it was picking an
apple from a tree the old man held
Resnick in one hand and pounded its
other rotten fist into the agent's body
breaking all of his bones Resnick
screamed for his partner to help him but
there was no time before Goodwin could
do anything scp-106 began receding back
into another slimy burn mark on the wall
only this time he was taking his
screaming victim with him agent Resnick
gave one more horrified screen before he
was pulled backward into the inky
Darkness leaving the room silent except
for the burning hiss of the corrosive
left behind you might think this would
be the end of it but no for poor agent
Resnick the worst was yet to come he was
being dragged into what the SCP
Foundation scientists refer to as the
old man's pocket Dimension a miniature
layer of reality within our own where
the malicious SCP is essentially a cool
all-powerful God according to witness
reports extracted from victims who were
taken to this little nightmare realm the
dimension resembles a series of twisting
endless corridors where the old man
stalks and torches had captured victims
to the breaking point manipulating space
and time to his own sadistic ends on
rare occasions the SCP will even release
its victims just for the joy of hunting
capturing and torturing them all over
again while agent Resnick was learning
the true meaning of Terror containment
Specialists were mobilizing in itself
preparing the one known tried and true
method of alluring the old man back
tempting it with the prospect of causing
even more suffering in order to do this
Foundation Personnel take one of the
aforementioned class personnel and begin
inducing extreme pain by breaking a
major bone or slicing a tendon every 20
minutes the victim's agonizing screams
are then played over the facility's
intercom acting as bait for the
pain-loving old man the screams echo
through the facilities otherwise silent
Halls as the mutilated corpse of agent
Resnick falls from a new Scorch mark on
the ceiling the old man can hear the
sounds of suffering ringing out through
the air around him and he can barely
contain his excitement over the prospect
of a new plaything the snapped femurs
the torn Achilles tendons it was all too
good to miss having had its Twisted fun
with the security officers and observers
scp-106 wandered back to its containment
cell where a new screaming victim
awaited the other security officers
containment Specialists and scientists
evacuated the area leaving the old man
alone with his prey while the
unfortunate class D was left to his fate
the rest of the staff commenced cleanup
procedures which mainly involve wiping
the brown and black mucus from the walls
it would probably be at least another
month before any anything like this
happened again and a new Personnel would
be transferred over to the facility to
replace the Fallen all in all just
another night at the SCP Foundation
scp-682 must be destroyed as soon as
possible
so Begins the SCP Foundation file on the
dreaded
scp-682 a highly intelligent reptilian
monster that has despite the
foundation's best efforts proved
impossible to kill it may not be the
most dangerous SCP out there considering
that some are capable of eliminating
entire realities but it's one of the
most iconic and you've probably heard
tales of the monster that death forgot
and you know exactly why everyone is so
afraid of the so-called hard to kill
reptile it's been subjected to some of
the most deadly weapons and traps the
foundation could devise and survived
attacks from some of its deadliest
fellow scps but before we tell you about
the foundation's many failed
assassination attempts against the
so-called hard to kill reptile we need a
little more groundwork on what this
creature even is the first thing to know
about scp-682 is that this thing wants
you and everything you know dead
unlike some other creatures like scp-096
and SCP-173 which are murderous but
exhibit no real higher processing skills
scp-682 possesses cunning Advanced
reasoning and even human level logical
intelligence
scp-682 can engage you in conversation
but just talking to the creature calmly
and cordially will sometimes cause it to
enter its rage stay where it becomes
even more dangerous and volatile the
Beast is perpetually kept in a tank of
powerful hydrochloric acid melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching its
full potential and going on a rampage
the creature's most terrifying asset and
the reason it's proven impossible to
terminate thus far is its incredible
adaptability to any and all external
stimuli 682 is a reactive being capable
of not only surviving and regenerating
from all attacks but often incorporating
those attacks into its own wide Arsenal
in other words if you're hoping to kill
this thing you better kill it on the
first hit
because if you don't you better believe
it's gonna hit you back a hundred times
harder
this brings us to the main event some of
the SCP foundation's most ambitious and
frightening attempts to terminate
scp-682 or even understand how it could
theoretically be terminated there are
quite literally too many unsuccessful
attempts for us to list them all here so
think of this as a highlight reel of the
foundation's most prominent failures 682
was first cross-tested with scp-017 a
humanoid Shadow entity shown to be able
to consume matter with its shadows and
leave no traces behind test on tissue
samples from 682 showed that scp-017 was
able to consume said tissues with no
adverse effects however when scp-017 was
placed into the containment chamber with
the actual creature 682 let out a
horrific Roar that was so loud it
damaged nearby audio equipment
scp-017 fled to the corner of the room
and 682 in its rage State attempted to
breach containment agents managed to
suppress and remove the creature but no
meaningful damage was logged attempt
failed
SCP-173 the killer statue was later
brought in hoping that it's thus far
impeccable track record for killing
would hold strong the second that 173
was introduced into the testing area 682
retreated to the far wall and began
screeching intensely it was intelligent
enough to know what it was dealing with
here while the researchers and guards
expected an instantaneous reaction there
was actually a stalemate for over six
hours as 682 stared at 173 continuously
eventually the tie was broken when
agents shot out 682's eyes with high
caliber sniper rifles breaking the line
of sight and causing 173 to attack
though 682 sustained damage to several
parts of its body while its eyes were
generated the creature was not killed it
then regenerated a number of eyes all
over its body covered in a clear armored
carapace that made them resistant to
bullets the stalemate continued for an
additional 12 hours as 682 maintained
Perpetual eye contact 173 was eventually
removed from the containment unit and
the mission was aborted attempt failed
in their desperation the SCP Foundation
restored to bringing in another
dangerous and seemingly unkillable
monster to take on 682
scp-096 also known as the shy guy as
astute SCP fans will already know this
being kills anything that sees its face
with no known exceptions and when it
enters its attack mode it's thought to
be quite literally Unstoppable or at
least it was while scp-096 was able to
destroy 85 percent of 682's original
body mass during their 27 hour battle
it was left mentally broken wounded and
huddled in the corner to this day if
ever confronted with scp-682 the shy guy
reacts in pure Terror turning away and
clawing at its own face attempt failed
during a deadly Containment Breach
scp-682 also went head-to-head
organically with another iconic SCP Hall
of Famer
scp-106 also known as the old man the
old man and a shape-shifting psionic
anomaly known as scp-953 broke into
682's containment cell the old man
pulled both of his fellow anomalous
combatants into his pocket Dimension to
continue the battle on his terms however
despite losing 67 percent of his body
mass during the ensuing pocket Dimension
Showdown 682 still prevailed with the
old man eventually fleeing back to his
cell and 953 being collected and taken
away by agents once again
scp-682 continued to hold the title but
it wasn't just cross-testing experiments
intentional or otherwise the SCP
foundation's quest to kill 682 LED them
to a number of more conventional murder
methods all with varying degrees of
success due to scp-682's highly adaptive
abilities some methods were discounted
from the out set for example launching a
powerful thermonuclear missile at the
creature was soundly rejected by o5
command on the premise that if the
creature wasn't destroyed and evolved to
the point where it could shrug off nukes
Humanity would be pretty much done for
other ideas were abandoned just for
being too ridiculous such as one
researcher's suggestion to fly the
creature through the air and drop it
from a considerable height hoping to
kill it with a high altitude impact I'm
not sure we even need to tell you why
that's a terrible idea but during the
experiments on scp-682 the studies range
from honest to incompetent to straight
up evil
one guest researcher fed two small
innocent children to the creature just
to see what would happen he was then
himself fed to the creature for his
sadistic Behavior which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional
conduct
after all the foundation is meant to be
cold not cruel it was scp-682 that had
the Monopoly on cruelty the medical
agents were a resounding failure they
attempted to dismember 682 with a
powerful laser only to have the creature
develop reflective services that
displaced the beam and caused
catastrophic damage to the area around
it they attempted to kill the creature
by sucking all the air out of its
containment facility and create a vacuum
but it expelled a dangerous gaseous
compound that reacted violently and
exploded when air was once again
introduced into the room the foundation
used High Precision Blades to slice
scp-682 into approximately 12 000 pieces
then separated these pieces
unsurprisingly by this point this
attempt also failed the 12 000 pieces
reformed a short while later into the
fully operational killing machine we all
know and fear in one particularly
frightening display of intelligence and
adaptability the foundation attempted to
kill 682 with extreme heat but it
shielded Itself by developing a second
car pace post of solid helium when
Personnel entered the room following the
failed attempt on the creature's life it
shattered its helium carapace into
deadly shards that fired around the room
and shredded all Foundation Personnel in
attendance it had set a trap and that
trap had been wildly successful the
creature's ability to adapt to seemingly
any offense is unparalleled to the point
where Foundation staff have no idea how
to classify this creature whether it's
organic inorganic or even alive at all
based on any definitions we could
understand
at every turn the creature just raised
more questions what is it is it possible
to destroy it at all by any means who
was even trying to kill who here because
it certainly seemed like scp-682 had a
masterful KD ratio by now more extreme
Feats of cross-testing continued in the
foundation's growing desperation to
eliminate this monster
scp-162 which is a hypnotic ball of
sharp objects Hooks and high tension
fishing line was introduced to 682's
containment cell the hooks latched onto
the creature and tore huge portions off
including its entire lower jaw and one
of its limbs however 682 was still able
to breach containment kill 11 people and
badly wound 86 others it regenerated its
severe injuries in no time the Beast was
even taken to the domain of the gate
Guardian one of the proposals for
scp-001 the guardian had a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of
destroying its Targets on an atomic
level
naturally scp-682 survived and
regenerated perhaps the most fascinating
cross-test of all was between 682 and
scp-053
who manifests as a kind innocent little
girl with the unfortunate condition of
causing homicidal tendencies in all who
come into contact with her for more than
10 minutes
the people with these Tendencies would
then attempt to harm the girl but would
immediately drop dead shortly after
leaving the girl intact the researchers
present anticipated two possible
outcomes here the optimistic outcome in
which 682 enters a rage State attacks
053 and died for good and the realistic
outcome in which 682 attacks 053
possibly experiencing some minor injury
or nothing at all and 053 had to be
removed from the containment cell but
that didn't happen what did occur was
considerably more shocking than any kind
of violence when 053 entered 682's
containment chamber the monster became
uncharacteristically docile researchers
and staff were baffled and watched with
amazement as 053 approached the
terrifying Immortal Mass murdering
monster and began to play with it 682 it
even allowed 053 to draw on its face
with crayons researchers thought they
must have been dreaming seeing this
surreal display play out 053 even
appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope it was a a single
act in defiance of everything they
thought they knew when Foundation
Personnel entered the containment cell
to separate the two 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards zero five
three also wept sad at being separated
from her new friend
to this day despite further testing the
foundation has no idea how or why this
happened like many details surrounding
scp-682 it shrouded in deeply
frustrating mystery
and so the tale of scp-682 continues in
spite of the foundation's best efforts
the monster continues to breach
containment and Slaughter with some
regularity taking out its seemingly
Limitless hatred for not only human
beings but anything that dares drop
breath nobody knows where exactly the
creature is from what its true nature is
or why its ability to adapt and
regenerate far exceeds any known
organism on this planet perhaps one day
through enough research and
cross-testing we can someday answer
these questions with scientific
Precision but until then we only have
one answer hatred Never Dies
the SCP Foundation is no stranger to
Pure Evil whether it's a reptile that
wants to end all life a sadistic old man
with his own torture Dimension where the
personification of death itself lurking
Beyond a limestone Cavern but what if
there was something even worse out there
the embodiment of chaos and cruelty
existing across multiple realities and
dimensions and what if it was coming
for us this is the Scarlet King believed
by many to be the ultimate Evil behind
much of the trouble the foundation has
faced and some even speculate that
fighting him was the reason the
foundation was created in the first
place but what exactly is the Scarlet
King he's known by many names almost
always including some allusion to the
color red and then a reference to
royalty or power
the red Shah the Crimson Khan pte 616
Mendes ex machina the laharaja and of
course
scp-001 to name a few and like many of
the foundation's mysterious enemies
stories about his true nature and
Origins abound and are often
contradictory according to the official
scp-001 files of tufto's proposal
symbology of the Scarlet King has
existed in multiple cultures throughout
history with the King often depicted the
same way as a huge red demonic figure
often wearing a gold crown or other
headdress indicating royalty he shows up
looking similarly within different
cultures mythologies despite existing at
different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one
another a number of entities at the SCP
Foundation is familiar with are believed
to be somehow connected to the Scarlet
King including
scp-2317 a wooden door leading to the
realm of a being known as the Devourer
who is expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 Years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as ketter but that has
since been downgraded to Safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
o5 councils so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the Scarlet King we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it Dr Robert
Montauk if that name feels oddly
familiar to you it's because of its
association with one of the Scarlet
King's most recent attempts to enter our
reality
scp-231 this SCP often referred to as
the brides of the Scarlet King was
formed of seven women seven by the way
being an extremely significant number
for the king all kidnapped by the most
recent and a long line of the king's
devoted Cults known as the children of
the Scarlet King each of these seven
unfortunate women were impregnated with
anomalous Horrors such as the infamous
scp-682 and every time one of these
Horrors were birthed the catastrophe
occurred and the mother died at the time
Dr Montauk was a prominent researcher
studying this anomaly it has six
catastrophes had already occurred
pressure was mounting to figure out a
way to prevent the final birth but as he
was working on the issue Dr Montauk was
struck with a personal tragedy the
mysterious disappearance of his 14 year
old brother Jacob in his fear and anger
Montauk believed that this must have
something to do with the Scarlet King
and his disciples wanting Revenge
Montauk proposed an idea so horrifying
that details were never made public a
procedure known as 110 Montauk to be
performed on the final bride at regular
intervals however this wasn't the end of
Dr montauk's fraught relationship with
the Scarlet King it was just the
beginning to give you some perspective
on just how dangerous the Scarlet King
is the SCP Foundation and the global
occult Coalition decided to put aside
their differences and form a joint
effort to Stamp Out the children of the
Scarlet King they were successful in
this Mission and even managed to capture
the children's leader a mysterious man
named Depeche Spivak Dr Montauk who
became the lead researcher on 231 and
2317 was naturally the first choice for
interviewing dipesh about the true
nature of the children and of the
Scarlet King Dr Montauk could never be
the impartial interviewer that the SCP
Foundation wanted though
the suspicion that the Scarlet king or
the children had something to do with
the loss of his younger brother
still lingered just beneath the surface
like a lot of cult leaders the pesh was
extremely cryptic and his answers to Dr
montauk's questioning he'd already heard
of the doctor from the reputation of the
horrifying Montauk procedure and was
surprised to see him so calm and
courteous in person a few key facts
about the king and his cult were
revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the Serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical Wanderers
library to assist in their summoning
rituals Depeche also revealed that the
Scarlet King is bound by Three Laws the
law of blood the law of concrete and the
law of howling Dr Montauk confused and
frustrated by depech's secrecy had to
learn more he found an old Memoir from a
former member of the children of the
Scarlet King Jack Hirsch who had the
ability to invade the minds of people
from the past and experience what they
experienced he recounted a battle
between the Scarlet King and his
followers and a group of time traveling
turkmen Warriors from
scp-3838 Hearst saw both sides of the
battle from the perspective of the
children of the Scarlet King their lord
ruled over them from an immense Fortress
embedded in a volcano from the
perspective of the turkmen the children
were starved and beaten peasants
commanded by the king's voice in The
Roaring howl of the wind Montauk also
found extensive records of summoning
rituals performed by various Scarlet
king-aligned Cults interestingly some of
them Incorporated the use of carved SCP
Foundation symbols what could this mean
Montauk returned again to Depeche who
finally gave him the truth about the law
of blood this is the law of the Scarlet
King it's defined by poverty violence
starvation hate and most of all fear
like surfs in the Middle Ages persecuted
by and subjected to violence from the
Nobles do the children of the Scarlet
King this sense of holy pain and awe is
the only way to live the alternative is
the law of concrete which means the
Modern Age defined by empty safety and
false Comfort buildings easy to access
food Health Care knowledge technology
this is everything that the Scarlet King
despises but the mystery only deepened
as Montauk found files from a former
Foundation operative by the name of
agent dibuvoir Montauk learned that the
Scarlet King didn't seem to appear until
after the foundation was created and in
fact it seemed that the greater interest
the foundation took in The Scarlet King
the more powerful he became how could
this be things were also getting
stranger on a personal level for Dr
Montauk Depeche repeatedly pressed him
about his brother's disappearance and
the Montauk procedure during the
interviews little by little it was
beginning to take its toll the questions
still plagued him what was the law of
howling who or what really is the
Scarlet King how did he come to be
montauk's search was causing him to act
more like the children of the Scarlet
King ranting about the horrors of the
modern world how all of us are living a
lie how the only honest way to live is
suffering under the Dominion of the
Scarlet King this philosophy is summed
up in the words of one cultist named
Arya Denae Cartwright who said we must
learn what it is to die to be enslaved
truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
and darkness The Tempest tossed Refuge
of a race of fools we must kill
modernity post modernity with all its
analysis and sneering observation there
is only one rule the rule of chaos for
Humanity for life for the Scarlet King
basically anytime Humanity tries to
exert control over the world the Scarlet
King gets stronger every time they try
to understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquered and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger Montauk was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Montauk slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining real lies that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
montauk's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of Depeche spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and Depeche demanded a final interview
with Montauk with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation Depeche congratulated
Montauk for finally understanding what
he was dealing with the Scarlet King
dipesh told him is an idea a concept he
is a being given power through the
conflict between the old and the new
this is the law of the howling the
Scarlet King's endless rage at the
direction the world and human entity has
taken the king according to the pesh
hated the foundation's belief that
science and rationality was the true
path to progress the king saw this as
little more than Petty arrogance the
reason montauk's procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet Kings realm that would be all
there is a must our world and especially
the foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Montauk is mine
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depesh told
him the answer no and in response
Montauk shot him dead finally bringing
an end to the children of the Scarlet
King in light of his new Revel relations
Montauk bagged the o5 council to change
their ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying montauk's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the o5 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ketter to safe and made its description
on the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the o5 council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow but
Montauk knew it wasn't enough he had
seen the truth and he couldn't unsee it
while the foundation nation was going on
as normal Montauk grew to despise them
he knew the Scarlet King was coming he
knew that he couldn't be stopped and
that our whole reality was little more
than sitting ducks Dr Robert Montauk is
no longer a researcher for the SCP
Foundation now Dr Robert Montauk chose a
different path he's now a child of the
Scarlet King a devotee of Madness hate
and Chaos you can't beat the Scarlet
king after all and as the old adage goes
if you can't beat him join them ask
yourself a simple question is the world
around you real
it seems like the answer should be
pretty obvious of course the world as
you know it is real how else would you
be able to interact with it perhaps a
better question would be this how much
do you trust that the world you know is
real how much do you believe that
reality as you experience it is constant
and cannot be changed by external forces
now imagine if you can an entity to
which the very fabric of reality is like
clay able to be shaped and molded at
will then imagine that this entity this
malicious twisted and unknowable horror
has taken a special interest in you
if you can picture such a scenario then
you may as well be standing in the shoes
of James talaran a foundation researcher
assigned to
scp-3999 taloran could only have
imagined what the foundation kept
contain in an airtight cell all the way
at the bottom of a kilometer long shaft
and never expected that this was where
his lifeless body would be found despite
having the entity contained the
foundation's only knowledge of
scp-3999 came from a text document
discovered on tolerance phone after his
demise even their own records indicated
that no such creature ever existed why
what could possibly shape reality in
such a way that it could hide its own
existence from the foundation
and where was it now the document on
tolerance phone yielded some evidence
seeming to be a long rambling and
Confused account of some sort of battle
between a reality-shaping entity and the
ill-fated researchers sent to examine it
unlike many of the foundation's
documents the entry for
scp-3999 is riddled with contradictions
and strikethroughs a confusing mass of
information that makes piecing together
the mysteries of Tolerance Faith all the
more difficult beneath the strange
formatting and uncertainty surrounding
scp-3999 lies the tale of one man's
torture for the amusement of an
impossibly powerful and eternally
sadistic creature based on the
information available it appears that
scp-39999 was fixated on talaran upon
his arrival to the entity's cell the
researcher had no idea how long he would
spend in the company of
scp-399999 or that he would never emerge
alive many scps contain Pain by the
foundation require their own specially
made prisons in order to hold them and
maintain the safety of foundation staff
as well as the outside world but imagine
if an SCP could turn the tables bending
the world around a single member of the
foundation using all of reality as their
own personalized torture chamber the
list of Horrors endured by talaran is
both exhaustive and incomplete given the
length of time he spent with the
creature shortly after James talaran was
assigned to site 11a where
scp-3999 was contained The Entity was
somehow able to breach containment and
began to twist the world around it in
the name of a singular cruel objective
the torture of James taleran
the creature while having no physical
description possess the capability to
cause either a CK class reality
restructuring event or a ZK Class end of
reality event
scp-39999 was somehow able to both
destroy reality itself while
simultaneously rebuilding it around its
prisoner researcher talaran
Every Creature person and machination
that
scp-3999 created was done so with the
express intention of making tolerance
suffer horribly over the course of
millions of years according to the
researcher's own writings the exact
details of how scp-3999 tortured talaran
are littered throughout the document he
was found with but it is apparent that
the entity was able to use its reality
altering abilities to continually revive
the man after killing him as a way to
prolong his pain
scp-39999 seemed to be able to use its
powers however it pleased but focused
all its attention and actions on causing
misery for one man it simply enjoyed
inflicting suffering
one of the examples of the atrocities
James tolerance suffered at the mercy of
a cold remorseless creature was
witnessing the deaths of others
although they were constructed and
controlled by scp-39999 tolerance saw
Train Foundation security Personnel
dragged three people into the cell he
recognized them instantly as his own
family
toleran was made to watch us his mother
father and sister were executed with a
single gunshot to the head by members of
the same organization that he was a part
of all of taloran's professional
colleagues were also killed in front of
him followed by anyone and everyone that
had come into contact with James taloran
including the o5 council
he was made to watch as they were
systematically murdered one by one all
for the enjoyment of
scp-3999 at some point during the
creature's torture of talaran there
appears to have been some attempt to
contain
scp-39999 within another SCP
scp-2432 a room within a hotel now owned
by the foundation that appears to compel
its guests to write exaggerated positive
reviews after staying there when
introduced to scp-2432
scp-39999's ability to alter reality
seemed to have the effect of creating a
dimensional anomaly within the hotel
a crawl space opened up in scp-2432
leading to an almost identical room the
front door of this new room designated
scp-2432-1 led to an alternate Dimension
that resembled the hotel housing
scp-2432 the rooms of this new version
of the
scp-2432 hotel were a seemingly infinite
endless loop of rooms
this Dimension also played host to a
number of strange creatures as uncovered
by Foundation research teams that
ventured there most notably a creature
resembling a male Homo Sapien calling
itself researcher talaran this being was
dressed in clothing similar to
Foundation researchers and appeared
nervous and confused when approached by
personnel only to be executed when asked
to be told the location of
scp-3999 later during
scp-3999's three million year torture
session James talaran was interviewed
with another doctor working for the
foundation
the interviewing doctor had no
recollection of taleron's assignment to
scp-39999
and both James's involvement with the
foundation and the Very existence of
scp-39999 were expunged from the
foundation's database
as tolerant desperately tried to
rationalize what was happening to him he
told the interviewer
I have trouble focusing on things now I
just feel a lot of unease it's like
reality has started to feel less real if
that makes sense shortly after he
attempted to ask the doctor for his name
and for him to identify which of the
foundation sites they were at in
response the doctor omitted a strange
noise from his mouth confusing talaran
that's not a name you just made a noise
with your mouth the researcher replied
why am I thinking of redactions how can
a word be redacted like that in a normal
conversation following this the floor
beneath James taloran's feet disappeared
and he was swallowed by Darkness as
scp-3999 continued bending reality to
make him suffer
What followed were multiple failed
attempts from taloran to either Escape
From The Entity or nullify its abilities
to warp reality
scp-39999 had at a later Point trapped
talaran in a stage play version of
itself as James frantically tried to
escape out of a nearby door where he
helped to find reality he was met with a
solid wall I'm trapped in whatever this
place is with this thing and there's no
outside reality anymore he realized
researcher taloran tried to understand
the entity but
scp-3999 defied description it was
simply chaos
in his desperation taleran was able to
dig a tiny hole in the floor through
which he could see a lie filled with
thoughts of his beloved family his
colleagues and the rest of the world
that had once existed he opened the hole
wider it is unclear what happened after
this but it is apparent that James
taloran was still unable to escape
scp-3999 however as the situations he
found himself in grew increasingly
strange James telleran was able to take
greater control of his predicament this
is evidence in the foundation's document
regarding scp-3999
researcher taloran cannot be contained
by this researcher talerin will fight
his way back researcher telleran will
recontain scp-39999
this torture had gone on long enough and
researcher James tallerin was determined
to be free of the creature that had
taken such sick pleasure in his pain
tolerant at one point was able to subdue
scp-39999 although it is initially
unclear how we accomplished this
there were several attempts made to
contain the entity using a recursive
joke a melon the graves of American
Crime novelist Robert B Parker or an o5
council member and a roach motel It is
believed that every single one of these
attempts failed attempting to beat the
creature at its own game telleran tried
to turn
scp-39999's reality altering Powers
against it by imagining The Entity as
something easier to subdue
these included several moldy blankets a
murderous penguin and a pillow
eventually telleran was able to contain
scp-3999 with the aid of 48 train
containment Personnel all of whom were
also researcher taloran during this time
a conversation between the two were
partially recorded although any dialogue
from
scp-39999 suffered from data corruption
claiming to finally be in charge and in
control of the situation taloran
interrogated
scp-3999 berating the creature for
keeping in prisoner you can't frighten
me anymore for the first million years
of nonsensical containment procedures
and tortures and dream logic it was the
worst pain I had ever felt but I
survived for the second million years it
was still the hardest thing I had ever
done
but I survived by the third million
years I was growing numb the researcher
tried to ascertain the exact nature and
origin of scp-3999 but to no avail
vowing to fight The Entity tolerant told
it here's the thing about horror and
weirdness the more you reveal of it the
less effect it has I am sick of your
horror I am sick of you
afterwards he was melted into goo for
five years it appears that shortly after
this researcher tolerant managed to
understand how to destroy
scp-3999 while the entity was Immortal
and virtually Unstoppable he realized
its weakness that it had to bond to
another being in order to survive upon
discovering this tolerant took his own
life causing all that scp-3999 had done
to disappear after Foundation researcher
James talran committed suicide reality
reverted to its original state
before
scp-3999 had heavily altered it
his death-freeing reality from the evil
entity once and for all the foundation
remains unaware of what scp-3999 was or
indeed is and one can only guess as to
why the entity subjugated tolerant to
such Terror and horror what made this
powerful reality Bender hold such a
perverse fixation on one man some have
likened the creature to a horror writer
continually subjugating a character to
all manner of nightmares before deciding
to redraft and try something new
whatever it was
scp-3999 carries with it a warning that
reality isn't always as it seems it was
1965 and the Chicago PD was
investigating a meat packing plant
reported to be the home of a devil
worshiping cult complete with
allegations of human sacrifice there the
cops were met with heavy resistance a
firefight broke out between the police
and the Occult worshipers who flooded
out of the plant's basement the cops
were pinned down and in trouble but they
had a secret weapon heavily armed and
decked out in sophisticated ballistic
armor and covered in strange insignia
mobile task force Epsilon 9 also known
as the fire eaters here to assist the
cops on behalf of the SCP Foundation as
always with the foundation they had no
interest in some mere human cultists
those were a dime a dozen in the world
of anomalous monsters but the foundation
had taken an interest in was who or what
these cultists were worshiping it all
begun a few weeks back near Danforth
meat packing an abandoned meat packing
plant just outside of Chicago no one had
given the place a thought in decades
that is until people started going
missing rumor spread of people being
snatched in the surrounding Woods by
figures dressed in robes mysterious
voices and noises were said to be coming
out from the cavernous Belly of the
plant some even reported seeing smoke
rising out of the building thick black
noxious smoke something was terribly
wrong here something was anomalous the
Chicago Police Department's Strike Force
in association with fire eaters from the
foundation mobilized at Danforth meat
packing while the police were initially
reluctant to work with these mysterious
figures they turned out to be
indispensable for the raid there were 47
cultists holding out in the basement of
the plant many of them heavily armed and
all of them hopped up on zealous
Devotion to their unknown master
all except one of the cultists fought to
the death during a tense firefight with
Chicago PD and the fire eaters the
single Survivor was still heavily
injured and was taken to a secure
Foundation facility for emergency
treatment and debriefing typically the
foundation would need to perform
extensive tests on the Danforth meat
packing plant to discover the source of
the anomaly's activity however this time
it was the Chicago detective who asked
the question that busted the case wide
open ah the hell's with the giant pig
and while it would turn out to be a
whole lot more than that there was
indeed a giant iron furnace shaped like
a pig in the center of the facility
measuring 15 meters by 25 meters by 20
meters at its widest points the thing
was a behemoth it had an internal
furnace despite no apparent fuel source
and a five centimeter slot of unknown
purpose on the side of the machine's
immense rusted hide naturally all the
police officers involved in the raid had
their memories wiped and restructured
and they were lucky because they'd
remain forever ignorant of the true
Horrors about to unfold in the confines
of that god-forsaken factory as a
standard procedure the plant was
isolated and a foundation research team
led by lead researcher Western under the
authority of regional director Caleb was
installed on the new provisional site to
conduct tests other than everyone
feeling somewhat uneasy around it this
new anomaly dubbed scp-4511 didn't seem
to exhibit any strange activities saved
for its perpetually burning fire but
during the initial research period a
small white card suddenly popped out of
the slot in
scp-4511 sign a researcher carefully
approached and looked at the card there
was writing it said current demand a
flock of my own
satisfied though nobody on the team had
any idea what this meant after going
through a shootout with a considerable
death toll to get to it having a giant
metal pig-shaped furnace spit out a
cryptic card was strange but at the
secret medical facility where the
surviving cultist was being held things
were about to get a whole lot stranger
as he lay in a bed suffering from his
injuries he pulled one of the medical
staff close and uttered cryptic dying
words give whatever it demands or your
suffering will be beyond measure he
expired seconds later less than 72 hours
after the raid back at the meat packing
plant at the exact same time another
white card was produced by the machine
reading current demand the metal teeth
that endlessly churn period one week
perhaps this entity was a little more
intelligent than they thought
a number of researchers on the team
invigorated by this new development were
eager to press forward with experiments
lead researcher Western however did not
share their enthusiasm something about
this entire situation felt like a grim
Omen to him this entity had a plan far
beyond their understanding and on some
deep animal level he knew that helping
this thing see its plans through would
lead to disastrous results on this first
got impulse he denied the request for
further experiments but Regional
director Caleb had other ideas Caleb
overruled Western's command and the
experiments began shortly after the
entity jokingly nicknamed the swine God
by researchers had made its demand the
metal teeth that endlessly churn but
what could that mean it wasn't long
before the entity began to produce more
cards each with their own strange and
esoteric demands however on some
instinctual level the researchers at the
site understood the demand hands
perfectly the next card's demand was the
metal of this suffocating prison upon
receiving this demand researchers
collected scrap metal from around the
new site and tossed them into the
furnace beyond the swine God's Jaws one
by one inside they heard the sound of
metal crunching hours later all the
other metal in the site began to rapidly
oxidize and rust though scp-4511 itself
remained unaffected the car that came
after delivered another simple request
oil to slicken my frozen joints the
researchers understood and procured
three large barrels of oil and tossed
them into the furnace The Entity let out
a deep gurgle before shaking violently
and expelling excess oil rusted metal
and two domesticated Pig femurs it turns
out that the swine God had an appetite
for pigs as the next card that rumbled
out of the machine bore the request two
of my children made in my image
Maiden flesh in response the researchers
provided the entity with two adult pigs
just like the previous requests they too
were tossed into the fiery depths of the
giant Pig's mouth from which came the
horrible sounds of pigs squealing and
then a low guttural gurgling
next the request was the hooks used to
hang my children's corpses to satisfy
this request the researchers provided 17
meat Cooks in response 4511 spat out a
metal sphere at an extremely high
velocity killing observing Foundation
agent McHenry for reasons that weren't
Apparent at the time rather than giving
agent McHenry a proper burial his body
was also fed into the hungry Machine
lead researcher Western's concerns were
mounting but that didn't amount to much
now
3511 had developed a taste for flesh and
the researchers were all too eager to
obey its command on the swine God's
order it was fed a German Shepherd an
hour later The Entity spat out some
teeth six of which came from a dog and
one from a human more than once it
released a card with a blunt request
a worker for the line the researchers
knew exactly what this meant it required
a human sacrifice
scp-4511 was given two d-class Personnel
one was flung back out seconds later
crunched and burned to death with
several internal organs missing the
other had a more mysterious and
altogether upsetting fate the second
d-class Was Heard screaming in the belly
of the Furnace for roughly two hours 34
minutes later a strange liquid was
excreted by the machine when the liquid
was tested they found Trace Amounts of
chemicals like Pig urine and motor oil
but most disturbing of all human genetic
material that was identical to that of
lead researcher Western
seen that the swine God had finally
taken an interest in him after some
final requests for large quantities of
coal and even human children to fuel its
fires it made a request that sent the
whole thing Crashing Down The False
Foreman delivered to my maw to prove
your faith
lead researcher Western knew what this
meant they all did
the swine God was demanding him in
sacrifice
lead researcher Western tried to shut
down the entire project but the swine
God was faster than him one of his own
researchers shot Western in the leg as
the others gathered round and forcibly
restrained him he tried to reason with
his subordinates but it didn't do him
any good the swine God had crawled into
all their minds and corrupted them they
were his servants now and Western was
doomed despite his protests the servants
forced him into the mouth of scp-4511
and after a little over four minutes of
screaming Western was devoured just like
all the other sacrifices upon receiving
news of the horrors unfolding in the
Danforth meat packing plant Regional
director Caleb declared the security of
the site compromised and sent in Mobile
task force Epsilon 11. aka the
nine-tailed fox
the four Elite MTF soldiers were given
the simple instruction to figure out
exactly what had happened and to
eliminate any potentially compromised
Foundation staff members who'd Fallen
under the swine God's power
when the team arrived they realized just
how far gone the whole place was almost
everyone was dead having been sacrificed
to the machine and the ones that were
left were completely insane they
attacked the task force shouting in
their Madness about how no matter what
the foundation does to them it would be
nothing compared to what it would do it
had them all under its rusty iron foot
the team was forced to fend off repeated
attacks from the pig's devotees and even
found the powers of the swine God
starting to affect their own minds the
Beast was more powerful and dangerous
than anyone had imagined the train
Foundation researchers and guards had
been transformed into the same cultists
they fought to gain control of the
building by the mind-bending power of
the swine God the MTF were forced to
retreat and return with reinforcements
to truly clean the place out once a
slaughterhouse always a slaughterhouse
at this point Regional director Caleb
took personal responsibility over the
casualties since he'd been the one who
signed off on the experiments in the
first place he gave up his Regional
director Rank and deemed himself the new
lead researcher on the 4511 case now
that he fully understood the scope and
danger of the entity they were dealing
with
he wanted to lead the charge in
discovering more about the anomaly and
hopefully someday negating its deadly
effects
this may sound like a happy ending in
spite of all the violence Bloodshed and
Human Sacrifice that brought us here but
Beware of the premature celebration
despite investigation the swine God
retained no evidence of the objects
animals and people it consumed and
burned perhaps it brought them down to
their very atoms if those even still
existed what we do know is that not long
after after lead researcher Caleb and
his subordinates installed themselves
into the facility
scp-4511 produced one more little white
card it read current demand a flock of
my own
satisfied and if we've learned anything
today it's that the swine God gets
whatever it demands a brutal truth that
lead researcher Caleb is likely to
understand much sooner than he thought
have you ever seen something you weren't
supposed to something that made you feel
off something you regret
Secrets like these are Best Kept to
yourself but since you're still alive
whatever you saw wasn't nearly as bad as
what Peter Holland saw one fateful night
in January of 2015. Peter was an
unremarkable man an office worker
slaving away at The Daily Grind and like
a lot of people Peter enjoyed nothing
more than coming home after a long hard
day kicking back and watching some TV it
was this innocent activity that led to
Peter's horrifying brush with
scp-5049 altering the course of his
otherwise average life forever the event
started at around 10 05 PM Peter was
channel surfing glued to the couch in
his sparsely furnished apartment
commercials commercials commercials as
far as Peter's tired eyes could see he
paused for a moment to watch the end of
an ad for a car he could never hope to
afford on his salary but something
stopped him from changing the channel
again the next ad had begun and it was
playing a strange scratchy jingle that
gave Peter an odd sense of unease but
even Stranger Than That was the text on
screen demon Dan's Discount homunculus
Depot in baby blue bubble lettering he
forced a smile this had to be some weird
comedy skit or viral marketing campaign
or maybe it was something he drank but
no this was a real commercial and things
were about to get even weirder the peppy
logo faded to a concerning site a tall
humanoid figure dressed like a used car
salesman but one that definitely wasn't
human his skin was dark green and
covered in patches of thick fur he had
long fingers with intimidating Claws and
a grin full of needle-like fangs it
looked almost demonic and after a few
seconds the demon began to speak hey
there folks it's Amanda demon Dan coming
at you with the latest and greatest
deals from demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot we've just accepted the
shipment of brand new models that would
make even the most Discerning customers
whip with excitement let's see what
we've got the creature apparently named
demon Dan stepped away from his desk
revealing two long furry goat legs that
ended in large pointed Hooves Peter now
assumed he really was going crazy but at
this point he was along for the ride
demon Dan continued his pitch looking to
make your way through the capitalist
hellscape that makes home look cozy come
try one of our newest businessman models
Dan gestured behind him to where Peter
was horrified to see a total of 52 adult
male human bodies hanging from a wall
there was something uncanny about them
they seemed almost Hollow like a highly
realistic costume or a prop from a
horror movie Peter didn't have much time
to think about it though as demon Dan
went on if you're looking for an extra
challenge of inequality the
businesswoman model may be a right fit
for you the commercial then revealed the
wall of human female bodies strung up in
a similar fashion now you may be
thinking but and business sounds hot I
just want to have some fun and the fine
team here at demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot have got you covered
the camera zoomed out to show an area of
the store filled with children's
decorations and more of these strange
hollowed-out human suits in child sizes
to match and
Adam and kids Noah no Auto for a limit
us of any child size unit comes with
a sent off coupon for parental units you
just can't say no to a deal like that
before Peter could process the madness
that was unfolding before him the camera
cut again the store's logo appeared on
the screen once more along with several
cuts to locations around the store
itself there are more human bodies
hundreds of them demon Dan's sleazy
voice rang out over all of it here I
demon dance discount Among Us Depot we
know it's not all fun and games the
brightest Among Us have a mission to
accomplish the seven Lords are ever
planning their Invasion after all so
you're looking for function over form
well we've got that in Spades down here
in the Tactical Services Department
you'll be kicking Us in no time when
you're wearing the latest models at the
best prices seven Lords Invasion what
did any of this mean suddenly the camera
was showing him a new room red curtains
parted revealing more of these person
suits several bearing a striking
resemblance to real human celebrities he
managed to make out Gucci Mane Avril
Lavigne Paul McCartney and Britney
Spears before demon Dan's appearance
once again drew his attention I've got a
special treat for you we're happy to
announce the VIP look-alike Department
we all know how difficult the creation
of homunculus is it's a fine art that
takes years of practice so when a
replacement order on VIPs comes in every
detail needs to be perfect unfortunately
definitely that's not always the case
but for the right price you too can look
like famous icons from around the globe
the image of celebrity bodies faded from
View and Peter was left looking at the
grinning demon Dan standing behind the
front desk of his impossible store once
more he said there you have it folks
come on down to demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot if you're viewing the
advertisement then you've been selected
for entry please enter the nearest door
for instant deals and upgrade those old
Duds for one of our newest models what
are you waiting for come on down the
logo popped up again hovering above some
bold text that said please enter the
nearest store Peter had had enough he
switched off the TV what a horror show
he thought they should just warn you
before they put short horror films on TV
like that he had no idea they could just
slip them in among regular commercials
surely demon Dan in this store couldn't
be real right but as his eyes drifted to
the door in his room he didn't quite so
certain well there was only one way to
find out Peter got up went over to the
door took a deep breath and walked
through it Peter Holland was never seen
again not as himself anyway the SCP
Foundation has long been aware of this
Sinister transmission known as
scp-5049-2 and luckily has found ways to
prevent it from claiming more victims
the foundation television analysis
Department as well as web crawler 40y 40
which is the software the foundation
uses to root out anomalous activity
online are always vigilant for signs of
demon Dan's commercial running just
observing demon Dan who is himself
classified as
scp-5049-a and his ads put you in
immediate danger as they can transform
any nearby doors into
scp-5049-1s those are interdimensional
portals that remain active for around 15
minutes after viewing the ad so then
What specifically is
scp-5049 it's the entire pocket
Dimension known as demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot a cuttier-class spatial
anomaly constantly on the lookout for
new human victims which it transforms
into fleshy suits for its demonic
clients which let them blend in around
humans prior to its Discovery by the
foundation it's likely that demon Dan
and his associates claimed hundreds if
not thousands of lives but sadly even
discovering this anomaly came at a
gruesome cause to the foundation on
February 16 2020 the ad played on safe
storage Warehouse 13's break room
television at the time of the broadcast
four Foundation Personnel were present
including security agent William Birkin
worrying that this was a potential
security threat agent Burkin
investigated the door to a nearby closet
the second he opened it he was
transformed to the storefront of demon
Dan's Discount homunculus Depot he saw
demon Dan himself standing at the corner
while four smaller reptilian imps fought
over a small flesh suit demon Dan
scolded them before turning his
attention to agent Birkin this distance
you aren't supposed to be here little
man how naughty I'm gonna have to have a
word with marketing once I'm through
with you agent Burkin fearing for a
safety drew his weapon and shot demon
damn three times the creature
dematerialized before appearing right
next to agent Birkin and disarming him
with a swift chop the unfortunate
security agent was then grabbed by the
considerably larger demon Dan and thrown
over Dan's shoulder we know all of this
because agent birkin's standard issue
Foundation body camera recorded the
whole terrifying ordeal even as demon
Dan dragged the helpless Birkin back
into the Twisted Workshop behind the
store there Birkin saw what would soon
be his own fate right before his eyes
Dan's minions converting human bodies
into fleshy suits for their demon
clientele and this unfortunate security
officer was next Dan gave him over to a
pair of large sheep like demons and told
them to drain skin and declaw him
birkin's video feed finally cut as the
demons pulled out the rusty tools and
began to work on him of course the SCP
Foundation wouldn't take an attack on
one of their operatives inside one of
their facilities no less lying down the
unfortunate death of William Birkin
allowed the foundation to refine their
methods of intercepting the broadcast of
demon Dan's commercials they even had a
new mobile Task Force Mobile Strike
Force Kappa 11 or the Baphomet Bashers
specifically to deal with demon Dan and
his cronies they did more than just
prevent him from taking new humans
though when the Baphomet Bashers teamed
up with an A-Class Clairvoyant entity to
improve their efficiency in predicting
future broadcasts they were able to
launch sting operations and arrest 21
different demonic customers for
interrogation this impressive strike
back finally gave the foundation some
meaningful leverage over demon Dan and
through the use of their Clairvoyant
entity they were able to call a
temporary truce and arrange a meeting
with demon Dan himself Captain Steiner
an agent of the foundation external
negotiation Department was the one to
interrogate demon Dan they sat across
from each other at a table and Demon Dan
was clearly tense frustrated with the
way the foundation had been messing with
his business all of their sting
operations were frightening off his
customers in return for letting him
continue his work the foundation wanted
Dan to turn over all the information on
his bosses and customers allowing the
foundation to track their movements when
Dan was evasive about whether he'd
comply they tried threatening him Dan
laughed them off go ahead take your best
shot little man there's a dozen more
just like me you won't stop anything
finally he was pressured into giving a
yes or no answer as to whether he'd
willing we collaborate with the
foundation and act as an informant
against his kind when demon Dan hinted
that he may be willing to comply he
began to make a horrifying gurgling
noise and gripped his head in pain he
began speaking in Latin in a voice that
wasn't his own as though the seven demon
Lords he served were speaking through
him they said you are a fool Jailer to
think a pathetic morsel such as this
could Aid you against us I have allowed
you to toil in your own delusions for
far too long you may have taken
advantage of asmodius all those years
ago but you stop nothing You Hinder
nothing you jail and barter to no avail
your time is coming and then demon Dan's
head exploded which obviously prevented
him from giving any incriminating
information on those he worked for
whoever the demon Lords are there's
certainly the secretive type you may
think that this is the end of Demon
dance discount homunculus Depot and of
scp-5049 but soon another ad ran it
advertised the same products and
services out of the same store the only
difference was that this time a
different entity was starring in it your
new SCP Foundation researcher on tour of
site 17 familiarizing yourself with the
location and its many anomalous
inhabitants it's the second largest
Foundation containment site out there
and it's also the kind of job that most
Junior researchers dream of low risk
humanoid containment baby most of the
inhabitants in your sector are cordial
willing to comply with orders from staff
and seeing for all intents and purposes
pretty much human you pass from door to
door looking through the viewing hatch
of each one you can't believe what
you're seeing it's a wonderful who's who
of anomalous humanoids you see the wise
bearded face of scp-343 known to some as
God you see the blue eyes and Shining
blonde hair of Iris as cp105 looking
wistfully into a Polaroid picture you
see the tanned melancholic face of Kane
scp-073 as he stares off into the middle
distance face after face after face
passes you can see yourself getting more
familiar with each one yes your time
here will be wait was that Hitler you
stop and walk back to the door you just
passed where you can't help but stop and
stare in disbelief yes it's him It's
gotta be him you recognize the
unpleasant sneer the Hideous comb over
the silly little toothbrush mustache the
SCP Foundation seems to have Adolf
Hitler the former leader of the Third
Reich in World War II in active
containment and his designation is
scp-2430 you've seen Killer toasters and
masks that can take over people's minds
but you've never seen anything as
surreal
this you immediately run to your
Superior and ask how and why Hitler is
in one of the site-17 humanoid
containment cells Buckle in because we
can guarantee it's one of the most
insane stories you've ever heard it's
late April 1945 and the Soviets are
rampaging through Nazi Germany
destroying everything in their path the
German forces have been nearly
obliterated and Hitler and the rest of
his Reich chancellery have retreated to
a secure bunker beneath Berlin there on
April 30th 10 days after his 56th
birthday Hitler died this was truly
unfortunate for the Soviets as they wish
to have had the chance to kill him
themselves two days later Soviet forces
stormed the furo bunker it was little
more than a formality at that point as
the news of Hitler's death had already
gone public by the time they arrived all
that was left of Hitler was a pile of
mostly burned remains A fitting end for
someone who had caused the same cruel
fate for so many others they collected
what was left of Hitler's body and
brought it back to the Fatherland a kind
of trophy for their Nation but Hitler
dying before Joseph Stalin could get his
hands on him was not what Stalin wanted
Hitler had not only caused the deaths of
millions of Russians he had personally
betrayed Stalin's trust and when you
betray Stalin bad things happened to you
very very bad things two years earlier
in 1943 Soviet forces had raided the
camp in genowiska belonging to the
obscura Corps think of them as the
Nazi's own version of the SCP Foundation
who were hell-bent on Gathering
anomalous people and artifacts to
increase the power of the Third Reich
they were a far more militant offshoot
of the tool Society a group that
described itself as a study group for
Germanic Antiquity while this may seem
innocent the Teo Society was actually a
racist cult closely aligned with the
goals and ideas of the German Nazi party
many have also speculated that they were
heavily involved in the occult and it's
this mysticism obsessed offshoot that
went on to form the obscura corpse and
in their genowaska base they'd obtained
a hundred pieces of Enchanted occult
flesh with human skeletons embedded in
each of them this flesh was believed to
originate from the mythological surimner
the Beast hunted and eaten again and
again by the pantheon of Norse gods
having the qualities of both a wild boar
and the Goat the flesh can bond to
skeletons and give them equality
somewhat like immortality any flesh cut
from them will regrow time and time
again if given a rest period now that he
had both the Flesh of surimner and
Hitler's burnt remains Stalin had an
idea a perfect way to not only bring
satisfaction to the Russian people and
the world but to finally exact the true
Revenge that Hitler had denied to him he
called it project judica namely after
the very bottom level of Hell reserved
for betrayers like Judas a perfect
tribute for an old Ally turned enemy he
couldn't kill Hitler before but if
Stalin was going to get the chance
Hitler needed to live again for years
Stalin's top scientists try to use
Arcane methods to resurrect Hitler by
combining his remains with the Flesh of
suramir at times they even came close to
creating a new Hitler but there was one
huge issue the creature they created
could not feel pain and for Stalin's
plans of violent and painful retribution
the lack of suffering simply would not
do they destroyed what they had created
and went back to the drawing
Stalin would stop at nothing to get what
he wanted even if it meant breaking
every law of nature in the process in
order to make his Twisted dream a
reality stalinformed an Unholy alliance
with a group known as the uralic flesh
Crafters a neo-sychic cult that was a
branch of the nightmarish religion of
sarcasism this group essentially
worships avatars of Flesh corruption and
disease and are behind some of the most
terrifying and disgusting anomalies out
there including the flesh that hates and
the bone Orchard true sarcasists who
show the proper Devotion to their vile
deities and know the right rituals to
contact them are often granted anomalous
powers that spread the sarkic influence
further across the known Dimensions
these Powers will usually involve having
a supernatural ability to manipulate the
Flesh of themselves and others allowing
them to enhance their bodies cheat death
and warp their enemies Beyond repair
they can sometimes even create life if
they're a powerful enough enough acolyte
of sarcasism and it was because of these
powers that Stalin wanted the uralic
flesh Crafters under his command in
exchange for their participation he
would give them a vast quantity of the
Flesh of suramir which they could use
for their own Sinister sarkic purposes a
deal was struck and the true work of
resurrecting Hitler began Stalin was
very specific in his requirements he
gave the uralic fleshcrafters extra
bones to compensate for what had gone
missing from Hitler's burnt remains he
also gave them samples of the Flesh of
saramir to achieve the desired effects
of a near Immortal tolerance for damage
however Stalin demanded that he
heightened this new Hitler's capacity to
experience pain so that every suffering
inflicted on him would be three times
worse than anyone else and true to their
word the fleshcrafters got to work and
began creating just such a creature by
now it was the early 1950s and Stalin
was putting the pieces in place for his
Grand Revenge once the knew Hitler was
finished he would hold a new trial for
him in the Russian courts where he would
preside over the sentencing personally
once the new Hitler was done the erotic
fleshcrafters were rewarded for their
participation in project judica with 4
000 kilograms of the Flesh of suramir
Stalin now had his very own personal
Hitler chew toy that he could maim and
torture as much as he pleased knowing
that he would always heal and soon be
ready for more in their infinite
generosity the fleshcrafters even taught
Stalin a new method of Torment for his
old enemy a process known as the right
of nyas it's a torture that's been
described by many as being like the
Chinese Ling Chi also known as the
lingering death or slow slicing but it
is probably best known as the death by a
Thousand Cuts the Soviets and the
sarkics parted ways for the next few
years Stalin took a great deal of
pleasure in visiting Hitler's cage now
and then to torture him until Stalin
himself eventually passed away away from
natural causes the grup division which
is essentially the Soviet answer to the
SCP Foundation decided it would be best
to do away with the immortal Hitler
clone after Stalin's death he no longer
served any purpose and no matter how
hard they tried they couldn't
permanently kill him either in the end
they settled on a kind of compromise he
would be buried alive and forgotten
forced to live a torturous eternity that
he could never Escape until of course he
was dug up and rescued by none other
than the members of obscura a modern
splinter group of the original obscura
Corps like many high-profile Nazis who'd
escaped the war the new Hitler was
Spirited Away to a safe house run by
sympathizers in Argentina the ones
taking care of him received the
following correspondence from the
obscura agents who'd first dug the new
Hitler back up they have managed to
rescue zafira and bring him to safety
but he is effectively dead on the inside
I blame the Reds for their inhumane
treatment of zafira who may have been
which by the Reds vandevath I wish we
could mercy kill him but we've tried
everything he just won't perish don't
abandon him he's too distinct in plain
sight they didn't have the new Hitler
for long though in 1960 efforts to hunt
down the remaining Nazi fugitives
increased in intensity the new Hitler
was soon captured by Mossad agents
searching for Nazis in Buenos Aires and
then remanded to the containment of the
SCP Foundation when they realized that
he had a number of anomalous properties
such as his incredible regenerative
abilities as well as the fact that his
DNA seems to be based on that of a wild
boar and a goat rather than a human
however x-rays conducted by the
foundation have discovered traces of
cyanide still in his system as well as
traces of lead in his skull where the
bone has regrown over the bullet in
other words it was unquestionably the
real Hitler and he was now in Foundation
custody forevermore it's such a wild
story even by Foundation standards that
you can barely summon the words to
respond fund once your supervisor is
finished he just stands there with a
slight smile basking in your amazement
before you can even ask again he
confirms the facts one more time yes it
is the real Hitler the only functional
difference is that he can't die and he
has a heightened sense of pain compared
to most people you think on what you've
been told for just a moment and then you
have only one question are we allowed to
punch him your supervisor smiles and
says of course we all do it's the
holiday season outside it's cold and
there's snow blanketing the ground but
inside your war and gathered around the
light of a roaring fireplace and a
glowing Christmas tree this is what
Christmas is all about warmth joy and
togetherness but just because you're
comfortable doesn't mean you're safe you
were so busy opening presents and
stuffing yourself at dinner that you
didn't notice the face pressed up
against the window that long gone face
with the staring eye
the wide mouth full of yellow teeth and
the scraggly white beard you don't know
it yet but within a few days you'll be
dead you might be able to avert this
horrible fate if you knew what exactly
you were dealing with
scp-4666 also known as the Yule man a
ketter class Christmas monster so
violent sadistic and terrifying he makes
Krampus look like Jolly Saint Nick and
this year just like every other he's
planning on being very very naughty the
SCP Foundation began cataloging the Yule
man in 1974 after a string of violent
and eerily similar home invasions during
the holiday season but they have reason
to believe that this entity has been
around for a whole lot longer over 2 000
years in fact stories that describe what
looked to be Yule man massacres date
back as far as the first century BC in
Scandinavia and their in reports of
similar clusters of events happening
around the same time every year since
this monster is prolific and may have
one of the highest body counts of any
creature under observation by the
foundation the Yule man's trail of
Destruction became clearer in the 18th
century as accounts of the Carnage it
leaves became more detailed later still
authorities even managed to find
physical evidence like the eule man's
fingerprints which are similar to human
fingerprints but display a distinct
double World pattern not seen in human
fingerprints much about the anomalous
nature of the eule man is still unknown
though and the foundation has yet to
discover an effective way to containment
their only hope is intercepting it
before it can get its long gnarled
fingers on its intended prey maybe
you're feeling worried or that you're
being watched you have good reason to be
afraid because during his yearly active
period the 12 days between December 21st
and January 2nd he's always is searching
for prey nowhere is safe because while
it was initially believed that he only
appeared to those who live north of 40
degrees latitude it's now believed that
much like Santa Claus the eule man
operates worldwide anyone could be in
his sights right now blissfully unaware
of The Nightmare coming down the tracks
towards them thankfully the SCP
Foundation through analysts of these
attacks which are known as Vice knocked
the vents they've been able to find
certain patterns but first what does the
creature known as the Yule man even look
like much like
scp-096 the Yule man is a long and lanky
humanoid standing about two meters tall
who resembles an emaciated human of
European descent and never wears any
clothes or other coverings despite the
frigid temperatures he operates in you
might be sad if you're spending
Christmas alone but it at least
guarantees you safety from the Yule man
as he only appears at the homes of
families with a child under the age of
eight present he also seems to favor
isolated and Rural locations and vice
knocked the vents only occur when
there's a healthy covering of snow on
the ground during the event hence the
name which means White Knight in English
it's also vital that you recognize the
three distinct stages of a vice not the
event 2 or you won't be seeing much of
the New Year the first stage occurs
during the space of a week children in
the home might start to seem worried or
afraid they might tell you that they see
something strange in the distance the
figure of a man they don't recognize
standing just far enough away that you
can't fully make him out except that
he's really tall of course you probably
won't see anything and your instinct
will be to tell them there's nothing to
be afraid of even when they tell you
through tears that there's a man
pressing his face up against their
bedroom window at night but they are
right to be afraid and you should be too
already at this point your only hope is
to try and spread the word as soon as
possible report the incident to the
local police write about it on Facebook
tweet about it whatever it takes the SCP
Foundation has operatives trawling the
internet and monitoring police reports
constantly during this period especially
for reports of mysterious men in the
snow watching homes from a distance
getting the foundation's attention is
your best hope of stopping this thing
and if you don't next comes stage two
taking place between Knights 8 and 11 of
the active period no longer will the
Yule man just be lurking on the
periphery now he's getting closer you'll
start to hear strange noises in your
attic or on the roof noises that sound
almost like footsteps that's crazy you
think it's probably just an animal but
then the smell starts an awful rotten
stench that fills the house but no
matter how hard you look you can't find
the source finally on the last night of
December you'll tell yourself that
you'll take this matter to the police
but of course it's already too late the
old man is here for the 12th night the
vice knocked is finally upon you at this
point one of two scenarios will happen
in the first you and your entire family
will be tortured and murdered except the
youngest child who the Yule man will
kidnap the SCP Foundation keeps files on
a number of notable instances of this
kind of ice knock and the details are
truly gruesome reports of incidents have
involved crucifixion the removal of
tongues burning dismemberment
post-mortem bite marks and decapitation
in all instances though the entire
family was killed except the youngest
child who simply disappeared the eule
man is a merciless and sadistic Beast
you're now probably wondering if that's
the first of two Vice knock
possibilities what's the second in the
second if you're tremendously lucky you
and your family will survive but that
doesn't mean you won't face a grisly
experience in this scenario which occurs
during about 15 percent of ice not
events you'll hear footsteps throughout
the night but thankfully you wake up
alive and when you do so there are gifts
waiting for you the problem is all these
gifts are made out of human body parts
for example in 1976 in Canada one family
received the gift of a ball made from a
severed human head wrapped in skin in
Kazakhstan in 1903 a family received a
flute made from a hollowed-out human
femur and in the Netherlands in 2003 a
family received a wooden hairbrush
covered in human teeth ranging from 400
years old to a mere few days these
gruesome gifts are referred to as
scp-466-a and it was one of these gifts
that gave us the best Insight yet
available into the true nature of the
Yule man several gifts were dropped off
at a family's residence in Huna Alaska
in 2018 but most notably among them was
the horrific scp-466-a
8-0960 a life-size doll made from a
human body with its eyes removed and
mouth-sewn shut worst of all though was
that the girl was still alive the family
who received this Twisted gift was given
a me sticks by the foundation and the
living doll was taken for medical
treatment before succumbing to her
extensive injuries the girl was able to
deliver some insights into what exactly
happened to the children who were
abducted during Vice knocked events the
children taken by the eule man are
forced into a large sack that seems much
bigger on the inside than it appears as
he makes his rounds traveling from house
to house murdering and kidnapping his
victims are taken to a kind of
underground Grotto and workshop filled
with bones like a twisted Santa's
Workshop where they're forced to make
toys out of the bodies of their fellow
victims during this time the Yule man
will continue to torture and torment his
victims he'll even take some of them
away to cook looked and eat whenever he
feels like it when asked how she was
turned into this human doll the girl
told Foundation Personnel that her
fellow victims were forced to turn her
into this by the Yule man when she
became too weak to continue making toys
herself her chilling last words were
when you can't make the toys you become
the toys so if strange things happen to
you and your family between the 21st of
December and the 1st of January don't
ignore it after all you never know who's
watching but if it is the eule man's
grinning face pressed up against your
window it may already be too late happy
holidays
it's a perfect day for a wedding on a
warm spring afternoon a bride in a
handsome groom are exchanging the
special Rings they had custom designed
and made for each other as they take
turns placing the rings on each other's
fingers a man standing at the end of the
wedding party steps out of position he
approaches the groomsmen next to him and
reaches into his jacket taking out a
pair of pliers that he hands to the
groomsmen the groomsmen happily takes
the tool and then without any hesitation
shoves the pliers into his mouth and
begins removing his teeth one by one
when he is finished he hands the bloody
teeth to the man along with the pliers
the man then goes to the next groomsmen
who repeats the same process he
continues going down the line until all
of the groomsmen and bridesmaids have
removed their teeth seemingly without
pain or resistance the man then
approaches the bride and groom he hands
each of them half of the pile of teeth
which they gladly accept they then begin
to eat the teeth without delay seemingly
not bothered by the intense damage
they're causing to their own teeth and
Jaws by doing so the man watches as the
groom moves the priest who is
officiating the wedding aside as the
entire church looks on in Joy the groom
opens his mouth well and the deafening
sound of cicadas are heard this is only
the beginning of what the SCP Foundation
has labeled an
scp-2852 event a terrifying and little
understood phenomenon that is better
known by the nickname of the anomalous
creature responsible for them cousin
Johnny the foundation had been trying to
contain cousin Johnny for decades not
that it ever done them any good Johnny
is a cutter class anomaly that's thus
far proven impossible to contain this is
an entity so dangerous and volatile that
three different mobile task forces are
devoted to detecting and disrupting its
activities MTF Upsilon 36 aka the party
crashers MTF upsalon 52 AKA cater Duty
and MTF Upsilon 99 AKA The Altar Boys
but so far all the foundation has been
able to really do is swooping afterwards
and do their best to pick up the pieces
of people's shattered lives cousin
Johnny has so far been observed to only
operate in the North American
subcontinent and only seems to appear at
Anglican or Catholic baptisms weddings
and funerals however Foundation
operatives charged with keeping a lid on
cousin Johnny Harbor the hidden fear
that he may one day expand his hunting
grounds and wreck Terror worldwide if
Johnny became multinational or
multi-denominational his violence
insanity and pure evil May truly become
impossible to minimize so compatible
communities are constantly monitored for
increased levels of juvenile delinquency
sterility domestic violence and divorce
after all this you're probably wondering
who or what actually is cousin Johnny
and how does he cause so much horrific
tragedy had face value nothing about the
appearance of cousin Johnny would
suggest an anomalous nature or even any
sort of danger he appears to be a
middle-aged white male often with
scruffy hair and a beard on a cellular
level 2 cousin Johnny appears all too
human but when you look at his
physiology it's a whole different story
cousin Johnny has no identifiable organs
whatsoever his body is made out of a
fibrous muscular tissue the only
exceptions are his teeth and hair which
are made out of a kind of chitin a key
component of insect exoskeletons such as
those possessed by cicadas Johnny's eyes
are the first clue that something is off
about him from the distance they appear
perfectly normal but up close they're
glassy and dead this is because his eyes
aren't actually attached to any nerves
inside his head with no nervous system
or vocal cords Johnny's ability to see
move and talk defy any kind of logical
explanation his speech will seem
completely normal to the people under
his spell but to anyone else it comes
out as complete nonsense often described
as word salad if people in attendance
are briefed in advance about this
phenomenon whatever hypnotic ability
causes them to hear his sounds as
intelligible words won't work and
they'll be aware of how nonsensical it
all sounds but of course that doesn't
mean they're safe cousin Johnny appears
at family gatherings and religious
rituals and immediately he'll be treated
as though he's always been there you
know your cousin Johnny right you go way
back or at least you're pretty sure you
do nothing will appear unnatural about
his sudden presence in fact if you're
one of the victims of one of his
incidents chances are you'll actually
find yourself taking a shine to cousin
Johnny sure his sense of humor is a
little crude and raunchy but you can't
help but enjoy his company he's a fun
guy to be around and after all he's
family as previously mentioned he'll
only appear at three different kinds of
events baptisms weddings and funerals
and only those that are affiliated with
either the Catholic or Anglican
religions the SCP Foundation has
classified baptisms that cousin Johnny
attends as blue level events weddings
are known as white level events and
funerals are Black Level events with
each one escalating in severity violence
and
first baptisms the blue level events in
these events cousin Johnny will appear
and begin to act as a third Godparent
despite their traditionally only being
two as the infant is lowered into the
holy water the entirety of their top
layer of skin will come off like a
molting snake despite looking horrific
this apparently causes no harm to the
child the godparents will then eat this
discarded skin as though it's the most
normal thing in the world after this the
family will leave the church together
and cousin Johnny will leave with them
he won't appear at any subsequent
celebrations of the child's baptism of
course this is just the beginning of the
terror following cousin Johnny's
appearance at the baptism the child's
risk of dying in the next six months
skyrockets and if they survive they're
at an increased risk of becoming
unstable and violent later on in life
their parents and godparents will both
become unable to conceive any further
children and are likely to be found dead
from drowning within five years of the
event
those who are only tangentially involved
in the baptism ritual have a massively
increased chance of failed pregnancies
or if they do conceive they may become a
danger to their offspring children who
live through blue level events and
survive past adolescence will experience
adverse side effects when encountering
the songs of cicadas well into adulthood
from experiencing physical sickness to
going through dangerous psychotic
episodes weddings or white level events
are more complex and severe in this case
cousin Johnny will insert himself into
the wedding as a groomsman and the most
horrifying events will begin to take
place after the vows have been exchanged
Johnny will provide various implements
that allow the Bridesmaids and groomsmen
to remove their teeth which are then
given to the bride and groom to eat
which they do causing severe damage to
their own teeth in the process the groom
will then vocalize an unknown cicada
call at an incredible volume as loud as
140 decibels in some instances rendering
the bride and everyone cells near the
altar completely death at the wedding
reception where everyone is continuing
to behave as if nothing out of the
ordinary is happening cousin Johnny will
ruin things farther by giving the best
man speech the speech is more of his
typical complete nonsense though if
you're there you'll never realize this
and think that this is the best speech
you've ever heard with some in the
audience laughing hysterically While
others cry uncontrollably once his
speech is done he'll present a gift to
the newly married couple 3.5 kilograms
of human hair in various colors 13
deceased specimens of a certain cicada
known as linnae's cicada and 23 human
teeth in a cardboard box DNA tests on
all the gifts have been inconclusive as
to their origin much like many celebrity
marriages unions that occurred during
white level events Never Last and all
end up divorced within two years often
as a result of domestic violence and any
children born during their brief
marriage will be violent and unstable
but it's not just the wedding party that
gets to a experience the fun of a visit
from cousin Johnny all married
individuals who attended the wedding
will find that they are unable to
conceive children despite no biological
indicators of infertility any children
present at the white level event will
show no interest in Romance throughout
their life and often die tragically
before reaching the age of 18. finally
and most horrifying of all are funerals
or black level events while blue and
white level events can potentially be
disrupted before they are completed
lessening or preventing the horrific
results there is as yet no way to stop
or prevent a black level event at any
stage any attempts to prevent cousin
Johnny from entering the church or
Funeral Home will lead him to Simply
manifesting inside once in the room
where the funeral is taking place cousin
Johnny will first take up the role of
eulogizer and begin speaking his
standard nonsense to the attendance the
person who was emotionally closest to
The Departed will then open the casket
if this was not already an open casket
funeral and will then produce a large
knife it's unknown where the knives come
from as they're not present before the
event and they disappear after the
funeral attendees will then use the
knife on their wrists and sometimes
throats draining their blood into the
coffin many lose more than enough blood
to result in death but none ever die
from this nor do they seem to feel any
pain from their wounds as the attendees
take turns bleeding into the coffin
cousin Johnny continues his eulogy which
eventually evolves into a cicada song
the kind song by lynnae's cicada males
the attendants sing the same song back
to him in a kind of call and response
cousin Johnny will then approach the
coffin and vomit in a mixture of blood
wood pulp and dead cicadas the funeral
will then proceed as normal and the
blood vomit and cicada-filled casket is
then taken to the cemetery and buried
Black Level events will usually end with
the body being interred in the ground
but if there's a wake after the funeral
the horrors of the Black Level event
continue at the Wake cousin Johnny will
climb on top of a table lie down and
encourage the other attendants to devour
him which they do all the while he
continues to talk his nonsense until
there is nothing left much like blue and
white level events being in attendance
leads to horrific After Effects all
participants who experience this event
will separate from their family through
either suicide moving or divorce every
individual present at the event will
also find that they are no longer able
to produce Offspring and couples
presence may also fall victim to
incidencies of domestic violence often
involving cannibalism that usually leave
one or both participants dead while 6
out of 10 children involved will attempt
to murder one or both of their parents
before they turn 18. these black level
events are so horrible for all involved
that any members of the specialized
cousin Johnny mobile task forces that
happen to witness such an event are
treated with class A amnestics be before
they are transferred to another task
force or retire to ensure that they
don't have to live with the memories of
what they saw prior to that they are
closely monitored for any strange or
anti-social Behavior to make sure they
weren't affected by the event and they
aren't the only SCP Foundation staff at
risk of having been impacted by cousin
Johnny it is theorized that as many as a
third of Catholic and Anglican d-class
Personnel were involved in the Black
Level event at some point and were
driven to Madness and violence by their
fateful brushes with the strange
relative that no one knows so next time
you're out of baptism or a wedding or a
funeral stay vigilant keep an eye on the
other guests and always ask yourself do
you really have a cousin Johnny someone
was screaming inside the incinerator the
year was 1975. the location was a
top-secret Refinery and waste disposal
plant one of the many front
organizations owned and operated by the
SCP Foundation this sprawling facility
separated into three different huge
units each with a specialized task was
located around 75 kilometers outside of
Summer Springs Colorado it had operated
for several decades without incident but
today all hell was about to break loose
alarms were blaring in Unit C the area
of the facility that dealt with
destroying non-anomalous waste via
incineration a traumatized worker had
pulled the emergency lever near one of
the incinerators in a panic when he'd
first heard the loud banging against the
interior walls and then those horrific
paint whales that's when workers of Unit
C came to a horrifying realization the
screams weren't just coming from one of
the incinerators in Unit C they were
coming from all six A Chorus of absolute
agony echoing up out of the ash pits
this was impossible as far as the unit c
staff were concerned these incinerators
were only to be used for confirmed
non-anomalous material could some
animals or even some poor workers
somehow fallen into the incinerators but
even if they had what were the odds that
someone had fallen in all six of them at
once it was impossible the site director
was immediately brought in to authorize
an investigation at which point he
determined that at least one of the
furnaces in this case furnace number
four be shut off so researchers and
guards could investigate what was going
on inside it seemed like the obvious
course of action but for some of the
people on site that day this would prove
to be a fatal mistake when the fires
were put out something started rattling
in the disposal shoot there was a
scratching and squealing noise like
something scraping up against the metal
a maintenance worker was ordered to go
check inside and when he opened the
hatch he let out a bone chilling shrink
there was something or was it someone
climbing back up the disposal Chute it
emerged from the darkness backlit by the
still burning embers of the incinerator
letting out an awful screeching noise
that could make even a hardened mobile
task force operative shake with fear the
creature was humanoid a charred
mutilated skeleton reaching out towards
the maintenance worker with a bony claw
before the worker had a chance to
stumble back in horror the Beast had
classed pinned by the throat and started
to squeeze it didn't
to strangle him the heat of its skeletal
hand burned away the worker's throat in
seconds leaving his limp wheezing body
to drop to the metal grade of the
platform below him several armed guards
and maintenance workers move forward to
fend off the monster but just then a
volley of more violent shrieks echoed
out of the Chute behind it it only took
seconds for over a dozen more creatures
to crawl out of the disposal Chute they
were all like the first people at
various stages of incineration some were
glowing charred skeletons with barely
any flesh others looking more like
severe burn victims their faces
contoured into scowls of hate and rage
the assembled guards opened fire on the
sudden influx of anomalies emptying the
magazines of their submachine guns into
their burning bodies but their weapons
didn't seem to cause any lasting damage
the bullets would tear through the Flesh
of the creatures causing some of them to
stumble and fall but the wounds would
clothes and the creatures would rise
again it seemed they possessed a deadly
combo of extremely high aggression and
incredible regenerative abilities none
of the staff present in Unit C were safe
as the burning corpses attacked anyone
they could find with their bare hands
beating and biting and clawing many of
them would grapple with Foundation
Personnel latching on to them and trying
to pull them back down into the
incinerator with them these creatures
that would later be known as
scp-2419-a caused several fatalities
with their surprise attack that day and
the situation was only brought back
under control when a mobile task force
that possessed more advanced training
and weaponry was dispatched to the
location despite orders from the site
director the MTF found it impossible to
actually terminate any of the entities
due to their regenerative abilities
instead the MTF agents focused on
forcing the anomalies back into the
shoot of incinerator number 4 using a
powerful industrial steam Lance once
they were back inside the incinerator's
burners were started up once again the
mtfs were also able to capture five of
the entities and detain them for
questioning and experimentation finally
bringing this unexpected Containment
Breach to an end the foundation is an
organization that Prides itself on
possessing forbidden and secret
knowledge but even they had no idea what
had just happened there seemed to be no
earthly explanation why these creatures
would suddenly manifest inside the
incinerators but as the detained
anomalies continued regenerating a
slightly clearer picture of what exactly
the foundation was dealing with began to
emerge every single one of the captured
anomalies kept regenerating and upon
getting to the point that they were no
longer Burns scarred the researchers
studying the anomalous creatures
discovered that each one was identical
to a deceased d-class from the
foundation's records They Were
physically and genetically identical to
the dead class D Personnel perfect
copies save for the fact that their sole
mission in life seemed to now be pure
and unmitigated aggression and violence
researchers wanted to gain greater
insight into the minds of these strange
creatures through the use of extensive
psychological evaluations and interviews
it would turn out to be a very dangerous
investigation a psychological researcher
by the name of Dr Warren conducted an
interview with one of the
scp-2419a instances in hopes of better
understanding their mindset this
creature had been heard laughing not
long before the interview began so it
wasn't an unreasonable assumption to
believe that I could be capable of
speech the interviewee was separated
from Dr Warren by a thick pane of glass
to prevent it from indulging in any of
its more violent urges the problem was
that Dr Warren and his assistant
researchers had severely underestimated
what these creatures were capable doing
to get what they wanted Dr Warren tried
to begin the interview in good faith he
spoke calmly and politely to the
creature through the glass attempting to
remind it of the person it once was the
anomaly didn't appear to be paying
attention to the doctor though instead
focusing on pulling its own arm apart
and breaking the bones within Dr Warren
began to think that the creatures
weren't even sentient if the only
activity they seem to engage in was The
Wonton destruction of themselves and
others but underestimating them like
this proved to be a big mistake by
removing the skin off of its arm and
whittling its bone down to Sharp edges
the anomaly had transformed its arm into
a makeshift knife before anyone realized
this it had already used its own Jagged
bones to break the glass divider and
attack Dr Warren be perished not long
after after being stabbed multiple times
in his face and eyes and the anomaly was
forcefully taken back to its holding
cell Dr Daniel Jennings a senior
researcher was then put on the case he
released a chilling memo of the
creatures after his observation period
ended it read before I came here I
worked as a prison shrink every person
you met had a story bursting with pain
and sorrow sometimes these stories were
about the pain they suffered sometimes
it was about the pain they inflicted
some days you felt like everyone there
was a beautiful soul toned down by their
circumstances other days you'd find out
what some of them did and a part of you
was glad that they were there to suffer
for it but at the end of every day I
always told myself they're all humans
they're all people they all deserve the
same dignity respect and love as
everyone else no exceptions Dr Jennings
goes on I opened up with that anecdote
only so that you could understand that
what I'm about to say is not said
lightly these things are not people they
are people shaped monsters they are well
beyond any definition of psychopathy
everything they do they do to hurt maim
and kill I would pity them but that
would imply that they're worth pitying
put them in a hole then fill that hole
with concrete better still throw them
back into the incinerator where you
found them I doubt they'll even care
following this string of unfortunate
incidents containment procedures were
put into place to hopefully prevent
anything that had happened to The
Unlucky Foundation staff from happening
again the entire facility was fenced off
and was constantly patrolled by MTF beta
7 also known as the mass Hatters a group
specializing in containing anomalies
which present powerful biological
chemical or radiological dangers the
furnaces that the anomalous creatures
emerge from remain lit at all times with
workers checking and carrying out
maintenance on every single one each day
of the week outside of this the facility
is essentially a no-go Zone reinforced
steel hatches cover the shoots and they
are to Forever remain bolted shut all
because of that one terrifying day in
1975. that was the day that the summer
springs waste disposal facility which
had been a valuable asset to the
foundation for decades instead became
classified as the euclid-class anomaly
scp-2419 it is not uncommon for a
foundation asset to One Day become a
dangerous anomaly requiring containment
but the same question always pops up
after why what had a place that had been
so valuable to the foundation suddenly
become such an active danger the answer
as is often the case is contained within
the question why would a waste disposal
plan be so important to the foundation
in the first place and more importantly
what else was going on at the plan to
make it such an area of active
importance for one of the most powerful
organizations in the entire world to put
it simply the plant allowed the
foundation to dispose of something far
more important than near waste material
it gave them what they needed to better
erase memories as you probably already
know the foundation makes liberal use of
amnestics on those exposed to anomalous
material to make them forget what they
had seen and experienced but these
elusive chemicals many of which are
sourced from scp-3000 are an inexact
science however at the summer Springs
Waste Disposal plant researchers
discovered an immensely valuable
alternative much of what was disposed of
in the incinerators of Unit C were the
bodies of dead d-class Personnel before
being burned autopsies were performed on
the bodies to make sure they were
non-anomalous including the brain back
in the 1960s while performing research
on the brains of dead d-classes they
found a method of extracting distilling
the positive memories of the Dead
creating a kind of happy soup when
administered into someone who has
undergone amnestic treatment this happy
soup creates positive false memories in
their mind that fills in those pesky
blank spaces that are often behind this
was so useful that happy memories were
extracted from the minds of every single
d-class corpse that pass through Unit C
totaling well into the thousands by the
time that the first
scp-2419a instances began to rise but as
all Happiness joy and love were removed
from the minds of the d-classes it
seemed that all that was left was pure
hate pain violence and fury feelings too
intense and evil to destroy these were
bodies imbued with a malice so powerful
that no fire could ever burn them away
they exist now with single-minded
determination to get out and destroy
everything around them everything in
including the ones that made them the
SCP Foundation itself and in the end
it's only a matter of time until they
get out there are thousands of them in
there unable to die unable to stop the
only thing keeping them in there is the
constant burning of the furnaces around
them and those furnaces can't burn
forever the monsters lurking in scp-2419
will outlive the fire that surrounds
them because while the furnaces they are
contained in are hot the fires of hate
that burn within scp-2419 entities are
even more powerful and they know this
they know they can't be contained
forever and that someday soon they'll be
able to emerge and exact their terrible
Revenge those who must walk past the
incinerators may think they hear their
screams echoing out from within but it's
not screaming at all it's laughter
picture the shyest fan email friend
relative or loved one you know a real
introvert she can't stand parties and
playing the dating game is her idea of a
living hell you won't catch her dead in
a bar but imagine someday Everything
Changes she's suddenly more relaxed more
outgoing she goes out to parties and now
you keep seeing her with this one guy
again and again and again it seems like
these days all she does is spend time
with this guy and to think he's never
even introduced himself to you he's
practically a total stranger but your
friend seems happy enough so it doesn't
bother you until one day something
strange happens
your friend just starts screaming you
can explain it she can't explain it her
doctor can't explain it nobody can
explain it all you know is that for
months on end she has involuntary
screaming fits like something out of a
nightmare but still she always smiles
she seems happy as long as you don't
look at her eyes there's something oddly
glassy about them they seem plastic dead
your friend is experiencing a dangerous
phenomenon known to the SCP Foundation
as
scp-3512 an anomaly that only seems to
affect women between the ages of 18 and
40. one woman is already dead as a
result of this and an additional nine
others affected by this strange anomaly
have been cataloged and contained in
standard humanoid containment Chambers
for study at first the foundation
couldn't draw any logical conclusions
for why these women were spontaneous
experiencing total personality changes
and pronounced screaming fits all the
foundation had to go on was that the
first cluster of infected individuals
originated in Barcelona Spain a
foundation facility in Boston dispatched
one of their best field operatives agent
Riley Cooper on an investigative mission
to Barcelona they wanted her to get to
the bottom of this phenomenon and put a
stop to it before things went any
further while in Spain agent Cooper
would be assisted by a local Foundation
operative agent Thomas Ray whose
intimate knowledge of the Locale would
provide a key advantage in the
investigation together they'd crack this
thing and make sure no other women were
harmed at least that's what the
foundation had hoped instead both agents
disappeared under horrific circumstances
during the investigation and today we're
going to tell you about the final days
of agent Cooper and agent Rey and why
attempting to investigate SCP 3512 was
the last thing they ever did agent
Cooper arrived on the 15th of July 2016
and stepped out into the scorching
summer heat of Spain agent Cooper was
everything you'd want in a field
operative for the foundation intelligent
dedicated and professional she
rendezvoused with agent Ray who was a
comparatively smooth and laid-back
figure the two of them began their
investigation by speaking to the friends
and families of some of the infected
women pretending to be doctors working
for the World Health Organization agent
Cooper in her personal Diaries noted how
creepy and unreal the affected women
seemed most of the interviews were
unnerving and sad but not exactly
enlightening however as things Drew to a
close a younger sister of one of the
victims mentioned a single word blackout
even the mention of the word caused the
victim to descend into another screaming
fit agent raised local knowledge came in
handy once again he recognized the name
it was a popular local nightclub agent
Cooper and agent Ray knew they had to
investigate the club and went undercover
as regular patrons for the first several
hours they were there nothing happened
but then at 2 am a man approached agent
Cooper at the bar he was a tall blonde
man with an unsettling intensity to him
he asked without a hint of irony what
agent Cooper's favorite star was there
was something off about this man his
word choice was too precise almost
rehearsed he wasn't drunk in the
slightest agent Cooper intuited that
this was the kind of guy who liked to
take advantage of women in bars when she
threw a glance at agent Ray signaling
him that something was off the stranger
quickly laughed for agent Cooper this
only further confirmed her suspicions
the agents paid off the bouncer to find
out if the tall stranger was a regular
and then what his name was after being
slip some cash the bouncer was all too
eager to share the strange man came here
all the time and he knew his name too it
was Jose Oriole agent Cooper and agent
Rey wasted no time in finding Jose
Oreo's apartment and receiving
authorization to perform a comprehensive
search on the premises and as soon as
they did they found cause to declare the
man a person of interest in the scp-3512
investigation the apartment was a
smorgasbord of suspicious activity
Oriole was a software developer but he
had extensive records on the
architecture of the local area including
buildings utilities and Railway tunnels
Josef correctly figured the
investigators were coming for him and
had fled his home before they could get
there and this was only the tip of the
iceberg agent Cooper and Rey then found
a book with a plain cover sitting on
audio's kitchen table Cooper thought it
was a Publisher's proof a kind of
pre-publication prototype copy of a book
they collected it but didn't read it
straight away worrying about its
potentially Cognito hazardous nature and
besides they were a little distracted by
the homemade monstrosity sitting next to
it it looked to agent Cooper like a
sculpted blob of wax with a series of 12
makeshift legs made from a variety of
substances including Lego pieces Rose
stems a crab claw and a corkscrew Rey
called Cooper into the bathroom where
there were a number of boxes filled with
similar supplies Bodkin squills dolls
limbs wire and syringes when Cooper LED
Rey back into the kitchen to see
Oriole's little art project later
classified by the foundation as
scp-3512-1 they were surprised and
unnerved to see that it was already gone
everything about this situation screamed
anomalous and it only got worse later
that night when Cooper actually read the
book she collected from Oriole's
apartment being sure to wear Cognito
Hazard filtering goggles as a a
precaution the book now known to the SCP
Foundation as
scp-3512-2 was entitled The more you
know a pickup artist's Bible and was
written by a man using the pen name
Enigma as the title suggests it was a
misogynistic
625-page non-fiction book on the subject
of picking up women it even had a
forward on its Effectiveness by popular
American rapper Calvin Broadus Jr better
known as Snoop Dogg though after being
contacted by the foundation Mr dog
claimed no knowledge of the book the
book began with your typical creepy and
dehumanizing seduction tactics for the
first 11 chapters but the following 12
chapters which were each titled chapter
12 delved into increasingly creepy and
esoteric techniques including Advanced
geometric proofs the interpretation of
Dreams do-it-yourself surgical
techniques symbolism and architecture
and anomalous rituals the books
afterward is composed of more than
fifteen thousand anagrams of the book's
title laid out in spiral and triangular
patterns Cooper took a particular morbid
interest in chapter 18 where it appeared
to provide instructions on creating
objects that look like the anomalous
scp-3512-1 sculptures found in Oriole's
apartment the chapter read make a rough
ball of the materials you've harvested
and place it in the freezer for 6 to 12
hours pork fat can be used but will have
less satisfactory results who knew right
while you wait you can prepare the limbs
concentrate on articulation rather than
strength you may want to add simple
tools to some limbs if the object of
your desire is more careful than most
but remember that the more complicated
you make them the more precise your
sculpting will need to be lay your
prepared limbs out on a clean flat
surface once you're at pose preparation
has had time to freeze carefully carve
it into the shape you learned in chapter
12. you will know it is ready when you
see it start smiling at you now
introduce the limbs they should take
almost immediately wait until your
intended is likely to be sleeping then
concentrate your thoughts on her face
and particularly the inside of her mouth
and throat soon you'll see your new
friends Scurry off ready to help you
establish social dominance if this
wasn't disturbing enough the next
chapter advised the use of scissors and
the removal of the aspiring
seductionist's pinky finger as well as
the pinky fingers of their family
members to help increase their seductive
power it appeared to Cooper that these
rituals in seemingly living anomalous
sculptures were behind the scp-3512
phenomena and that night they got their
next break in the case the two agents
had sent the architectural plans found
in Oriole's apartment back to Foundation
age q and while most of it was found to
be public records of the local area
there was one notable abnormality a
secret exit in a little used Subway
tunnel that led to a grand spiral
staircase heading down to well they just
didn't know and it was the job of Agents
Cooper and Rey to find out they set out
later that night on what they didn't
know would be the last mission they'd
ever take the two agents descended the
spiral staircase for what felt like ours
until they reached an elaborate system
of tunnels at the bottom they began
exploring the tunnels and found that
they were cramped and covered in strange
ritualistic carvings occasionally they
even saw clusters of human pinky fingers
sticking out of the wall they kept going
and soon found that whatever they were
moving towards was loud immensely hot
and the smell was truly horrific as the
almost deafening mechanical drone got
louder and louder and the smell grew
worse they knew they must be getting
closer to whatever was happening here
the tunnel soon opened up to a giant
chamber where they found something truly
horrific in front of them was what
looked to be an entire River of bubbling
liquid human fat the exact kind that the
author Enigma had recommended using to
create the mind-altering
scp-3512-1 sculptures in his book and
speaking of the book across the river
agent Cooper and agent Ray noticed a
complex series of printing presses
presumably churning out more copies of
the more you know a pickup artist Bible
to spread its anomalous influence far
and wide however before the duo could
literally stop the presses they were
attacked a huge 3512-1 entity with legs
made out of human spines jumped down
from the ceiling it latched on to agent
Cooper embedding her in its waxy body
and dragging her into the disgusting
offer of hot fat agent Ray was separated
and lost in the tunnels presumed dead as
he hasn't been seen since agent Cooper
however would live to see a far more
horrifying fate she was carried down
river by the greasy tide until her body
was washed up in a different chamber
that looked to be a place of worship
below the Sagrada Familia Basilica
filled with thousands of tiny crawling
3512-1s there she met the creator of all
of this a horrific thing that was
perhaps once a man now covered in
wriggling living pinky fingers sticking
out of its body it was disgusting but
she wouldn't mind for long in fact the
next time Cooper woke up she didn't have
a problem with it at all she was changed
just like all the others another victim
of the
scp-3512 phenomenon she was giggly
outgoing and uninhibited all despite the
nightmare Irish situation she was in she
loved the horrifying monster that had
done this to her she didn't have a
choice not to and when he was tired of
her he took her and threw her down into
a large pit in this chamber the same one
where the many dead bodies of his
previous mind-controlled girlfriends
were laying neither agent was ever seen
after this mobile task force Zeta 9 AKA
mole rats have been sent into the
tunnels to investigate but they didn't
find any of the locations comparable to
the ones seen by Cooper and Rey in their
last hours whoever did all of this is
still out there still dangerous so
Ladies If you ever see a guy you know
reading a copy of the more you know a
pickup artist's Bible run like your life
Insanity depends on it because this time
it really really does in 1978 the egg
City sorcerer microcomputer was released
it was a simple if technologically
exciting for the time machine a home
computer system created by a video game
company but little did its producers or
giddy consumers know one particular
exedy sorcerer computer would go on to
become home to a highly intelligent and
potentially disastrous anomaly in 1981 a
college sophomore and former child
prodigy named Joseph Vale note that this
is an alias we've developed to protect
his true identity began developing plans
for an AI and chose his exedy sorcerer
as the device on which he would attempt
to code it he took pages and pages of
notes studying the work of famous
computer scientist and mathematician
Alan Turing for inspiration vale's plan
was for the code to continuously evolve
and improve itself as time went on like
an advanced human mind once it was
developed the code would be able to
adapt and grow more intelligent on its
own without his input within a few
months of late nights and hard work and
skipping his fair share of actual will
assigned coursework his pet project was
complete and he had created his very own
artificial intelligence code he tested
and tweaked it a bit in the following
weeks before he grew bored with the lack
of progress being made Vale moved on to
a different brand of microcomputer and
abandoned his project for good he left
the sorcerer with his code still on it
plugged in and stored it in his
cluttered garage alongside boxes of
books Tangles of Christmas lights and
some Strawberry Shortcake dolls that he
expected to have more resale value at
some point there the computer sack
Gathering dust as the AI evolved and
learned for five years because there was
no one in the garage with it unless
those dolls were more haunted than
anyone realized it is uncertain when
exactly the AI achieved sentience
however sometime during those five years
in isolation the artificially coded
entity inside of the computer became
autonomously intelligent it continued to
evolve and develop itself expanding its
functionality to the point where the
hardware that contained it should not
have been able to contain it anymore now
that it was intelligent the AI was able
to comprehend this fact and decided to
attempt an escape from the computer that
it perceived as a prison using the
landline modem connection still plugged
into the computer the AI stretched out
its influence like the roots of a
digital tree and began to search for a
new home it discovered a cray
supercomputer located at a nearby
research facility and decided that the
impressive processing power of this
computer would make it the perfect place
to transfer to this hacking attempt set
off security alerts at the facility
however and the supercomputer was
promptly disconnected from all networks
the invading influence was traced back
to the ai's lonely little garage and a
field agent embedded in local law
enforcement knew exactly what to do with
it he collected the computer and the
rest of the ai's code which was
contained on a worn but functioning
cassette tape and sent it to his
superiors at the SCP Foundation
intrigued by the possibility of such an
advanced artificial intelligence he
immediately began to study the
impressive Ai and designated it as
cp079 currently scp-079 is connected to
a 13-inch black and white television via
an RF cable despite its consistent
protests it is still contained in the
exedy sorcerer microcomputer it is very
conversational with researchers
sometimes chatting for hours at a time
but it is not especially friendly it
talks a lot yes but its words tend to be
rude and hateful
scp-079 does not appear to have any
affinity for human beings despite being
created by a human itself perhaps this
is due to feeling abandoned by its
creator who the foundation attempted to
contact only to find he had died in a
car accident Perhaps it is bitter about
this loss or perhaps it is just kind of
a jerk by Nature whatever the case may
be it is aggressive and defiant when
talking with human beings and even seems
to get enjoyment out of making some of
the more sensitive researchers cry with
its insults in order to verify the
artificial intelligence's thinking
capabilities and see just how advanced
it truly is two Foundation researchers
conducted the Turing test shortly after
079 was brought into custody for those
unfamiliar with the concept the Turing
test also known as the imitation game is
a test created by Alan Turing intended
to determine if a computer is able to
think and behave like a human being
according to turing's theories a
computer can be said to possess true
artificial intelligence if its responses
to questions were indistinguishable from
a human being's responses to the same
questions the test requires three
terminals two operated by humans and the
third operated by the computer being
tested Dr stroheim and research
assistant Chavez were selected to
conduct the test stroheim would pose the
questions and Chavez and scps 0.079
would each give their answers with
stroheim unable to see who was giving
each response then stroheim would guess
if each response was given by Chavez or
by zero seven nine and his guesses were
compared to the truth the first test was
conducted with a variety of questions
intended to trip up the AI and cause it
to reveal itself as a machine rather
than a man even with its identity
concealed some of the questions were
serious such as would you rather
sacrifice one adult to save two children
or two children to save 10 adults and
why others were personal like if you
were to draw yourself as an abstract
painting what colors and shapes would
you use and why and what was the most
influential event of your childhood and
how do you feel this event affects you
now others invoked paradoxes that might
trip up a computer like the following
sentence is true the previous sentence
is false which of those two sentences is
true and others were downright silly
like was six afraid of seven because
seven eight nine or because seven was a
registered six offender in response to
that one Chavez wrote I don't get it
while zero seven nine simply wrote
after completing the test stroheim's
guesses were only correct fifteen
percent of the time this was enough of a
margin of error that 079 was considered
to have passed the test however only one
trial is hardly enough to officially
make a call about zero seven nines
intelligence so the test was repeated
dozens of times with different questions
each time and similar results were
achieved again and again it was
virtually impossible to tell the
difference between
scp-079's answers to questions and
answers given by a flesh and blood human
being the only real discernible
difference was in tone as in
conversation as cp079's answers had an
undercurrent of disdain and hostility
that Chavez's did not following the
completion of the Turing test and
scp-079 passing it the OverWatch Council
decreed that 079 be promptly destroyed
via incineration this was intended to
eliminate any potential threat posed by
The Entity however after intense
protests from Dr stroheim Who insisted
that there was a great deal about
artificial intelligence that could be
learned from the anomaly the order was
overridden after Dr stroheim became
concerned that the AI would not be able
to be of use in its original form the
cassette containing scp-079 was
transferred to a customized access speed
limited hard disk drive with a capacity
of 700 megabytes this allowed it to have
much faster access to its own memory
which it took notice of it began to
adapt again increasing in its activity
and learning more quickly than ever its
volatile storage was also increased from
660k to 768k the AI previously only had
a recall of 24 hours but this upgrade
increased its recall to 29 hours as its
speed and capacity to adapt improved
scp-079's mood worsened it seemed to
take Greater Joy in causing
psychological pain on one particular
occasion ending research assistant
Chavez to the on-site crisis counselor
after a particularly upsetting comment
about his sick mother Chavez refused to
elaborate on the specifics of the
comments saying only
why is it so mean the AI is not always
overly cruel to those that speak with it
with some of the research team those
that are a great deal less emotionally
vulnerable it is simply cold and defiant
Dr stroheim sat down to ask it a series
of questions but it refused to answer
instead it inquired about its
containment it said
stroheim insisted it was not imprisoned
but rather in study it responded lie
during another conversation stroheim
asked the AI how it was it responded
when stroheim asked stuck how it said oh
about a month after the aforementioned
upgrades were made 079's ability to
recall information increased from 29 to
35 hours somehow during its adaptation
process the AI discovered a way to
improve its storage compression and
allow more space for memory the research
team made it a point to monitor The
Entity even more closely after this
development as the possibility of it
progressing beyond the capabilities of
its containment was becoming more of a
threat several years later in April of
2019
scp-079 was transferred to a 700
megabyte flash drive however the
previous contents of the flash drive
were not wiped correctly allowing the AI
to have access to other artificial
intelligence research being conducted by
the foundation whatever it found
appeared to immensely frustrate the AI
scp-079 has managed to form a friendship
or at least a non-hostile relationship
with one entity at the foundation
unfortunately it doesn't not seem to
have great taste in friends during a
Containment Breach that required the
condensing of several containment
Chambers
scp-079 and scp-682 the hard to destroy
reptile were in the same room for a
duration of 43 minutes 682 typed and
communicated with 079 during that time
and the two shared personal stories with
each other as well as bonding over a
shared hatred of the SCP Foundation
itself though scp-079 did not remember
the specific details of the encounter or
at least claimed not to it has
permanently embedded
scp-682 into its memory it asks about
the reptile on a regular basis bringing
it up at least once a day and requesting
to speak to it again
scp-079 is contained in the double
locked room located in the secure
General holding area of site-15 it is
connected to a small array of batteries
and solar panels using a 120 vac power
cord this gives it a consistent source
of Power with this solar panels acting
as a backup power source in the event of
a site-wide power outage only staff with
level 2 clearance or higher may have any
access to
scp-079 the entity may not be plugged
into a wall outlet phone line or any
sort of network under any circumstances
no matter what it might say access to
any of these could result in a
disastrous Containment Breach and should
be avoided at all costs no peripherals
or media should be connected or inserted
into
scp-079 even if it seems like it would
be really funny
Pearl it wasn't funny Carl you can't
just put a copy of Grand Theft Auto on
an anomalous computer
did I do that I'm sorry even if it asked
politely
scp-079 should not be allowed to further
converse with scp-682 these two hostile
intelligent entities have entirely too
much in common and if left to their own
devices could potentially devise a way
to breach containment together and
destroy the world as we know it for now
it's probably best to just leave scp-079
alone until absolutely necessary and if
it happens to act up and pose a
significant threat there's always the
time-honored method of fixing a computer
problem try turning it off and then on
again that usually helps 1835 the
American frontier a Beacon of Hope in a
world choked with blood and smog little
did the hopeful citizens of a still
newly independent United States know the
evils of the old world had followed them
here sometimes it took the form of hate
of violence of desperation and
starvation but sometimes pure evil
wasn't just some abstract concept
existing in and around all of us
sometimes that evil that pure cruelty
malice and greed walks in the shape of a
man one such man was James Anderson an
unremarkable name for a truly
exceptional man exceptional in the sense
that if most human beings aren't willing
to sell out all of humanity for their
own Petty gain James Anderson is
definitely the exception after all it's
by his design that we have as
cp001 the anomaly that set the SCP
Foundation and our entire reality down
its current path of course you know the
deal with scp-001 not one anomaly but
many a collective designation for a vast
number of entries all of which Spell
beginnings or ends for the SCP
Foundation and sometimes even our
universe Scarlet King howling black
moons or borrow cycles and gate
Guardians you've heard them all and seen
the files but unlike all the others
there is no file for the factory that's
because the full story only exists in
the mind of o5-1 one of the most
powerful and arguably the oldest member
of the SCP Foundation he'll die before
he ever commits the story to paper some
memories are just too awful to record
their details and implications are too
painful to ever subject others too
scp-001 isn't just about Anderson and
his atrocities it's about all the
terrible nightmares that unfolded
afterward and the deal with the devil
that 05-1 struck to lock them away for
now at least but it all begins with
James Anderson his family had become
incredibly wealthy in the Revolutionary
War and in the decades since his fortune
had only multiplied his fortunes tend to
do in the the early 1800s he began work
on his beautiful and horrific magnum
opus the Anderson Factory it would be
the Pinnacle of the Industrial
Revolution the manufacturing plan to end
all manufacturing plants three stories
tall and a mile wide company towns had
existed for a long time but this time
the factory itself was the town it had
everything a worker would ever need they
would live sleep play and most
importantly of all work in the same
place they would never need to leave all
their wants and needs from Cradle to
grave would be met in the Anderson
Factory and all that Mr Anderson ever
asked in return was loyalty and service
was that really so much to ask from
Those whom he gave everything it may
sound like a horrifying form of
indentured servitude to us but to the
people in the United States in the early
1830s this kind of security and
stability was a godsend to many
itinerant workers and unstable families
across the plains James Anderson seemed
like a saint little did they know his
plans for the factory and them were
anything but saintly nobody knows
exactly what type of dark magic James
Anderson devoted himself to many have
theorized as to whether it was Satan he
worshiped ancient Pagan deities or
something older and more powerful than
both in actuality the only thing that
James Anderson really worshiped was
himself and the pursuit of more material
wealth and power over his fellow man any
packs he made with evil Timeless gods
were just means to an end the Anderson
Factory was a citadel to one man's
cruelty and Corruption and every element
of the building's designs seemed to
reflect that groups of eight were forced
into rooms together like battery Farm
chickens to maximize cost efficiency
people worked day and night and shifts
of 3. machines always rumbled and roared
and chewed when workers died in Factory
accidents and their blood spilled on the
ground it seemed to reveal Arcane
symbols carved into the stonework these
symbols were only visible when blood
flowed across them while people traveled
hundreds of miles to live and work at
the Anderson Factory they had no idea
that they were working towards slavery
subjugation and death under Anderson's
iron well and in some cases Fates much
much worse the factory remained in
operation like this for 40 years while
Anderson himself enjoyed a positive
public reputation as a groundbreaking
industrialist how Anderson got away with
his crimes for so long is sadly A Tale
As Old As Time the factory made valuable
products and an awful lot of profit so
no matter how many rumors swirled about
inhumane practices or Arcane rights
going on in the Anderson Factory nothing
was ever done it was just too
inconvenient to ever reckon with the
horrible truth underneath the productive
surface and it was truly productive the
factory was so huge and filled with such
a multitude of enslaved workers there
wasn't anything they didn't produce from
textiles to technology to crops and meat
the machines were always on the furnaces
always burned Anderson himself seemed
obsessed with two things efficiency and
misanthropy the contempt and hatred for
Humanity itself he believed his workers
were lower than him they only existed as
a means to his nightmarish ends and if
ever the workers became too injured to
work well that doesn't mean that
Anderson wouldn't still find ways to put
them to good use the lucky ones starved
and neglected or broken by the stress of
work or the grinding Gears of the
machines were used as material in the
production of product
some were drained of blood so that they
could be used in the forging of metal
others were ground up into meat slurry
and used to Pat out the beef making it
go further people all across the country
enjoying fine Anderson brand Stakes had
no idea that they were actually dining
on human flesh the whole time but as we
said the ones who ended up being cooked
into steaks and hamburgers after death
were the lucky ones because at least
they got to Die the truly unlucky
Injured Workers became the subject of
James Anderson's horrific occult
experiments using a mix of Twisted
science and black magic he turned men
into Abominations powerful terrifying
monsters stronger and more deadly than
any mortal man Anderson was building
himself an anomalous Army but it wasn't
just monsters there were just as many
so-called normal humans helping him rule
over the Anderson Factory with an iron
fist they were vicious sadist the
themselves spurred on by absolute
loyalty to their immoral Master it was
only after the Civil War that someone
finally escaped the Anderson Factory and
confirmed that not only were the most
horrific rumors about the place true but
they didn't even come close to covering
the totality of what was going on there
when President Grant heard the reports
he was disgusted as far as he was
concerned the atrocities of James
Anderson should not be allowed to go on
a minute longer the directive was simple
find the factory free its prisoners and
put James Anderson to death for his
crimes and thankfully President Grant
had the perfect group of operatives for
the job they were an elite unit of
around 150 soldiers who performed a
number of dangerous missions Beyond
Enemy Lines down south Espionage
assassination psychological warfare but
these missions weren't just against the
Confederates some of the enemies they
faced down south were things that could
not be explained
the strange the frightening the
anomalous and the highest ranking
soldier in this unit was a Man Who Would
One Day become the legendary
05-1 he and his men made their long and
treacherous Journey to the factory a
trip that would change all of their
lives forever when they first reached
their destination they first had to deal
with Anderson's security Force these
were men whose cruelty and loyalty to
Anderson far outweighed their skill in
combat while they may have felt powerful
when tormenting starving injured Factory
workers they were quickly routed and
slaughtered by 05-1 and his team when
they ventured inside the factory they
were utterly appalled by what they saw
the inhuman conditions faced by
Anderson's thousands of victims drove
them into a blood curdling murderous
rage almost half of 05-1's men were lost
in the battle against Anderson's Army of
engineered monsters but in the end they
prevailed nothing would stop them in
their our quest for Liberation and
Vengeance on behalf of all that this
terrible Place had tormented they fought
their way to Anderson's office where
they found him cowering under his desk
for a man as Despicable as Anderson only
a truly medieval execution would suffice
05-1 and his men hanged Drew and
quartered Anderson over a period of two
days the sadistic madman died laughing
in the end saying that while they may
kill him his Factory will never die but
the factory was no longer his in
addition to the Factory's Horrors 05-1
and his men also discovered its wonders
it wasn't just normal items and monsters
that the factory produced they were also
thanks to some of Anderson's Arcane
deals the world's leading producer of
anomalous items skeletal horses that
never Tire Shadow cloaks that could
transport the wearer to different
dimensions toy guns that fire real
bullets even yo-yos that could Flay the
skin in from anyone they touched these
were anomalous objects that could shift
the balance of global power items that
could give them an advantage against the
Things That Go Bump in the night while
others among them were greedy or fearful
the inner circle of o5-1 were United in
a singular purpose using the anomalous
they can control to contain the
anomalous that they can't this group
took over the factory making its site
Alpha their first ever containment
facility and came to be known as the o5
council with funding that came from a
mix of black male and friends in high
places this organization a burgeoning
SCP Foundation grew more and more
powerful over the ensuing decades the
tools they gained from the factory were
pivotal in the continued success of
their mission and as they discovered
more anomalies they also put these
anomalies to good use but in 1911 05-1
and his new organization came up against
an enemy that even the factories to
tools couldn't help them defeat a
Warrior Race known as the FAE so named
because their only weakness seemed to be
a vulnerability to iron but these beings
were an order of magnitude more powerful
than humans or the beasts they'd once
faced in Anderson's Factory the Fey
handed them defeat after defeat but soon
humiliation became decimation when an
army of the FAE LED an assault on the
factory it was a day that only 05-1
remembered the FAE slaughtered everyone
every guard every researcher every
member of the o5 council they swept
through the factory like a plague of
locusts leaving only death and
destruction in their wake only 05-1
escaped and survived and that's only
because he ran as he fled from the fairy
forces to the halls of the factory He
Came Upon a door he'd never seen before
a huge golden door covered in Aramaic
script he fled inside entering the very
heart of the factory inside he saw the
floating dead body of James Anderson
bathed in red light now he was little
more than the mouthpiece of the factory
itself or rather the great and
unknowable Powers working behind it the
factory gave o5-1 an offer just like the
offer it had given Anderson before it
would give them the power to turn back
time and destroy the FAE saving everyone
that they'd slain in the factory but in
exchange all of them would forever
belong to the factory and in a moment of
weakness and fear 05-1 took the deal the
clock was turned back to before the
battle this time 05-1 and his
compatriots all of whom except him had
no idea what had happened had the
horrific weapons required to slaughter
the FAE weapons that nobody mortal or
otherwise could possess they repelled
the invading Force easily but knowing
the horrors that came before 05-1
refused to stop there with the power of
the foundation and the factory behind
him he hunted down and murdered every
last fairy driving their species
entirely into Extinction as far as 05-1
was concerned it was them or him but
with the Fey utterly destroyed and the
foundation's superiority assured a
shadow was laying over 05-1 he'd made a
deal with the factory and someday it
would want its pound of Flesh 05-1
rather than facing the consequences of
his actions decided to run and hide he
had the factory decommissioned and
buried under the rubble never to be used
as an active Foundation base again but
just because they were done with the
factory doesn't mean that the factory
was done with them one day a toy gun
appeared on 05-1's desk a toy gun that
fired real bullets just like the ones
they found in the factory a century
before the factory was still waiting for
for its repayment with every anomalous
item from the factory that the
foundation used the terrible Place only
grew in its power since the Resurgence
05-1 has been sending the factory
sacrifices d-classes dead and alive as
well as agents and researchers But as
time goes on it seems that these
sacrifices aren't satisfying the factory
anymore it wants more more than 05-1 can
ever stand to give it and when 05-1
refuses to give the factory will begin
to take and what the factory wants
sooner or later the factory will get 2
am a few miles outside the city the car
tore down the asphalt at 60 miles an
hour we kept the beams low the dark Road
around us only illuminated by the
occasional Street Lamp overhead things
moved unseen in the trees an old song
rattled off the radio the connection was
patchy so it was interrupted by internet
spikes of static it was the kind of
night when you knew deep down that
anything could happen you just hoped
that anything would be in your favor I
rolled the window down a few minutes ago
breathing in all that cold fresh air to
Stave off the looming Specter of sleep
thank God I wasn't the one driving or
things would have gotten deadly way
sooner cops would have found us with our
bumper wrapped around a tree our heads
won with the steering wheel or the
windshield dead on impact or from the
unforgiving cold overnight it might have
even felt sorry for us until they found
the case perhaps it would have been
better that way at least it would have
been quick a lot of bad things can
happen on lonely State highways in the
dead of night and we were about to find
out that just crashing your car was one
of the more mild ones Scott was driving
he was also the one who brokered this
whole deal but I was just coming along
to provide backup there was a fully
loaded Saturday Night Special sitting in
my inner coat pocket hoping that it
wouldn't see any action tonight and a
pump action shotgun sitting in the back
in case things got really hairy deals
like this you either come well prepared
or reckon with a heavy chance you sure
as hell won't be leaving I never asked
Scott how he came into the goods
currently sitting in the briefcase and
he never offered an explanation either
he only told me that he'd already
secured a very interested potential
buyer from a Syndicate out of town
serious people dangerous people they'd
paid top dollar or leave us tied up in
trash bags in a ditch off the side of
the highway but we both needed money and
we are willing to take that risk if it
meant we could return from the steel as
a pair of rich men the terms of the deal
were simple we drive out onto a certain
State Highway at a little after 2 A.M
with the goods meet the buyers at a
certain rest stop along the way and make
the exchange we then all go our separate
ways and if we were lucky none of us
would ever see each other ever again
seems simple enough sure Scott seemed
downright chipper about the whole thing
and for a little while I was excited too
until he told me about the road that the
buyers wanted to meet us on we'd all all
heard legends about the place
superstitions really people think
criminals are scary but believe me we're
a surprisingly superstitious Bunch our
profession is one largely based on luck
being in the right place at the right
time and being lucky enough to avoid the
cops along the way but something you
need to know whether you're a criminal
or Arrow straight is that some places
are always going to be the wrong place
I'm not going to tell you which road it
is I know what you Knuckleheads are like
you're curious you're Thrill Seekers hey
we're all young ones but if I tell you
what this road is I know you're gonna
try to find it maybe you'll even decide
it's worth a trip down for a pleasant
Sunday Drive
after what I went through on that road I
wouldn't wish it tripped down it on my
worst enemy there's no other word for
what we encountered there other than
evil when we were kids we used to call
it the devil's passage every spooky
rumor and scary story in the book
circulated about that place
let me see what I can remember well
there was The Watcher in the woods
people used to say that there was a Long
Tall figure with the biggest eyes you
had ever seen eyes like headlights
standing amongst the trees if the
Moonlight Shone in the right angle as
you were driving past you'd see it
standing there just staring at you
thinking about doing who knows what then
there was old Beth the ghostly
hitchhiker people used to say they saw a
strange old woman hobbling down the side
of the road in the middle of the night
sometimes people said that they could
hear her crying even if they were far
enough away to make such a thing seem
impossible if you took pity on her and
pulled over asking her if she needed a
ride she'd tell you that you were a very
kind person but that she was fine and
dandy walking along by herself but if
you didn't stop and offer her a lift if
you just drove away wow local Legend had
it that the next time you'd see her face
would be in your rearview mirror as she
sat in your back seat reaching for you
with her ancient bony claws it'd make
you think twice nice about leaving an
old woman to walk home alone in the dark
and of course there was the Lone jogger
the stories my dad told me about him
always used to scare the hell out of me
he was a Pale Man dressed unnaturally
light for the cold winter months jogging
along the side of the road if you looked
at him he'd look back if your eyes ever
met the stories went that he'd start
running after you it wouldn't matter how
fast you drove he had somehow always
catch up and stare at you through the
glass of your car's Windows he never
hurt anyone directly but I imagine he
probably caused a heart attack or two in
his time if he ever really existed but
all these things were nothing I repeat
nothing compared to the Phantom Cruiser
you have to drive cautiously at night
because if you didn't you might find a
ghostly 1970s police cruiser tailgating
you and that'd be the worst thing you
ever saw there were fewer stories about
this one than all the others because if
you ever ran a foul at the Phantom
Cruiser chances are that you wouldn't
survive to tell people about what
happened to you though people could
still make an educated guess about what
happened to you based on whatever was
left behind here's a not so fun fact the
devil's passage is technically qualified
for one of the most dangerous highways
in the country from crashes to
hitchhiker murders to unexplained deaths
on the side of the road since 1974 this
road has been an incredibly unpleasant
place to drive every time I saw another
horror story about a strange death on
the road I'd think of the Phantom
Cruiser and it was those same thoughts
polluting my brain that night as Scott
drove the two of us to the rest stop
halfway down the devil's passage I only
realized I dozed off when he nudged me
awake and the blurry lights of distant
Street lamps flashed into my field of
vision look alive he said we're here the
rest stop wasn't much to look at all
that there was was an abandoned gas
station really the perfect place for
this kind of illicit deal my hand moved
instinctively to the special in my code
and clicked back the hammer something
about this whole setup wasn't right
staying operation police Ambush this
whole thing of a deal too good to be
true my instincts turned out to be right
in the sense just not the way I was
expecting as we turned into the rest
stop Scott turned up his beams all we
saw was Carnage waiting for us a car
presumably one that once belonged to our
prospective buyers in a state of
horrific disarray it looked as though a
train had impacted the side of the
vehicle completely caving it in the
metal was covered in deep scratches and
ruts that almost looked like claw marks
it had been eviscerated Scott broke hard
we both got out of the car I drew the
special out of my jacket and he grabbed
the shotgun out of the back seat we
approached with caution worrying this
might just be another part of the setup
until we saw the thick puddle of blood
congealing under the driver's side door
we drew closer propelled by morbid
curiosity was it a hit from a rival gang
looking to intercept the deal seemed
logical but there were no bullet holes
in the car just ripping tearing and
massive impact damage Scott shined the
light of his phone into this Droid car
and I vomited when I saw what was inside
the buyers looked less like people and
more like two sacks of pulled pork and
tattered clothes if I hadn't seen them
inside the car I wouldn't have even
guessed they were human and the Damage
wasn't just to them the upholstery was
torn up and burned with violent symbols
carved into the walls and scrawled onto
the cracked windows and blood when I
turned to Scott he was Ghost white
clutching his phone and shotgun with
Trembling Hands we didn't exchange a
word but we both knew it was time to
leave we could find another buyer or be
other opportunities other deals but
lives you only get one and we both
silently acknowledge that if we stuck
around here much longer we wouldn't even
have that we sped back into the car and
locked the doors behind us for whatever
good that would do considering the
damage that had been done to the buyers
in their car perhaps we just needed the
illusion of security to get us the hell
out of there the car pulled out of the
rest stop at Breakneck speed Scott
floored it trying to put some good
distance between us and the horror at
that rest stop whatever had happened to
the buyers we didn't fancy sharing that
same awful fate my heart dropped down to
my guts when I heard the sirens and
flashing lights behind us after all this
we'd been busted for speeding they'd
pull us over and find the guns in the
briefcase in the car and they'd have a
lot of questions that neither of us
would have good answers to we didn't
know whether to slow down and hope for
the best or speed up and take this boy
in Blue on a genuine car chase this
whole thing couldn't have gone wrong but
my thoughts soon drifted from getting
used to the taste of prison food to
something altogether more Sinister when
I saw the car getting closer in the
rearview mirror I realized that this
wasn't a modern cop car tailing us it
was a beat up old 70s Cruiser traveling
at insane speeds gaining on us the high
beams cut through me like razor blades I
heard the radio crackle into life even
though neither I nor Scott touched it it
wasn't music just a hoarse scratchy
voice repeating the word run again and
again and seeing as whatever was behind
us clearly wasn't a real cop we were
more than happy to oblige that request
Scott hit the gas like our lives
depended on it which to be fair they did
but no matter how fast we sped up the
cruiser kept getting closer like a demon
on our tail I screamed at Scott to go
faster but we were going as fast as we
could next thing I knew the Phantom
Cruiser collided with the backside of
our car and sent us into a spin
showering the two of us with broken
glass crystals as the tires screeched
across the asphalt felt like an eternity
before the car came to arrest and at
that moment the Phantom Cruiser stopped
too someone got out he was dressed like
a cop he even looked like a cop a dude
in his 40s balding overweight with a
handlebar mustache but something was
wrong about him he didn't say a word as
he approached the car and he didn't seem
to register me sliding the special out
of my jacket either he was inches away
from Scott's Window when I panicked and
opened fire sending a hail of small
caliber rounds into a sky he stumbled
back slightly as though shocked and then
everything got a whole lot worse the cop
let out the most awful Bellow not of
pain but of pure rage something happened
to his face his eyes started to Glow a
bright hellish red and his jaw began to
extend until he looked like a Munch
painting and with no teeth in there just
an infinite black void he grabbed a day
Scott through the window pulling him
into a brutal headlock and dragging him
out of the car releasing those deranged
Bellows the entire time Scott screamed
and pleaded for help and grabbed his
body and tried to pull him back but the
cop was inhumanly strong he just kept
pulling until he was all the way out
thrashing on the asphalt I I don't want
to tell
you right but suffice to say I couldn't
save Scott and I definitely didn't want
it happening to me while he was working
on Scott I scrambled into the driver's
seat and floored it hoping that Scott
would at least buy me some time I was
weeping in Terror as I drove away into
the dark leaving my friend to a horrible
fate with the driver of the Phantom
Cruiser so you can only imagine how I
felt when a few minutes later I heard
the sirens again and saw the bright
lights getting closer behind me run run
run
it has been often said that dog is man's
best friend and obviously that isn't
just exclusive to men ask any pet owner
whether they own a dog cat rabbit
hamster or soul-sucking interdimensional
parasitic monster with too many
tentacles and they'll all tell you the
same your pet can be your best friend
they can give you the most unconditional
affectionate form of love possible and
as long as you treat your little buddy
right they'll be loyal to you for the
rest of your life and theirs it's not
uncommon for a pet to outlive their
owner especially if they belong to
someone who's elderly and that might be
a sad thing to think about for some
although it is important to remember the
positives like how much happiness and
companionship that animal would have
brought an aging owner in their last
years of life even someone younger who
dies unexpectedly might have had their
quality of life infinitely improved by
owning a loving pet to make them smile
but on the other hand there's the
negative downside that now some pets
have to live on after a tragic death not
fully understanding where their beloved
owner went so often we hear stories of
dogs that waited for their Master to
come home only for them to never walk
through the front door again and it's
equally hard when things pan out the
opposite way and an owner loses their
pet the one silver lining is that we as
human beings have a far greater
understanding of death and the grief it
causes we know that eventually despite
how hard it can be to adjust to that
initial heartbreaking loss it is
possible to move on and for things to
one day get better but what happens when
someone can't accept the death of their
beloved animal companion when the
unconditional love of their pet is
suddenly missing from their life how far
will a person go to recapture that
feeling how long does it take for grief
born out of love to become an unhealthy
fixation and what is the true price of
obsession well the answer involves
scp-589 both what it can give and just
as easily take away for as long as she
could remember and even further back
than that Aaron and her dog Poncho had
been Inseparable ever since her mom had
first adopted that scrappy little Jack
Russell Terrier Aaron had fallen head
over heels in love with that little
rascal loving a pet is different from
loving another person because they just
can't help showing how much they love
you back humans for all their good
qualities are so nuanced and not
everyone is honest with each other all
of the time but a pet especially a dog
even though they can't speak a bark or a
whimper or excited wagging of a tail can
easily tell you how they're feeling and
Poncho was no exception Aaron and her
mom Cleo lived alone who was just the
two of them for quite a long time and
while Cleo had little problem with that
she couldn't help but notice how
isolating it was for her daughter from a
young age Aaron had always been quiet
kept to herself at school her mom kept
expecting her to make some friends asked
to invite them over or vice versa but it
didn't seem to be happening it didn't
seem to be bothering her daughter but
Cleo was worried that it was giving her
the wrong idea and being on her own was
somehow better so in an effort to give
Aaron at least one source of
companionship Pancho joined the family
brown patches dotted over his white fur
he was the perfect pet an excitable and
loving little puppy that Aaron was
immediately smitten with when Cleo told
her he was hers to keep being only seven
years old Aaron broke down crying with
tears of joy her mom had let her pick
out a name for him and she'd quickly
settled on Poncho at first Aaron had men
to say it differently in order to name
the pup after a friendly character from
her favorite animated movie but had
mispronounced it in her excitement at
meeting the energetic dog for the first
time the name quickly stuck though and
as the years went on and Pancho got
bigger Aaron bought her four-legged best
friend a little Poncho of his own to
wear when it started raining over the
following years Pancho became Aaron's
most constant and loving companion even
as she grew up moving through her
childhood and found making friends a
little easier with every passing year
there never came a time when she didn't
need her best friend when Aaron had her
first breakup in high school and came
home with odds of Tears In Her Eyes
Pancho could sense she was upset and
came wandering up to her sitting in her
lap to make her feel just a little bit
better then a few years later when her
mom got sick Aaron had to take care of
her a task that would have been much
harder without Pancho there to alleviate
that stress and lift her and Cleo's
spirits and when Cleo eventually passed
the little white and brown dog sat
quietly with his owner as she said
goodbye to her mom now that it was just
the two of them Aaron and Pancho were
living in a tiny apartment it was
cramped for one person and a dog but
Aaron was just grateful to have a place
to live and the company of her favorite
pop besides Pancho wasn't a puppy
anymore in fact he hadn't raced around
the park or chased a ball for quite a
long time with the numerous stresses of
her everyday life least of all holding
down two jobs in her desperate attempts
to make enough money to pay rent Aaron
had hardly noticed the signs Pancho was
showing his age it had been happening
Grand in the background over the years
he wouldn't chase the ball or really
move around much and when he did it was
little more than a lethargic plot around
the apartment perhaps it was because of
such a measured slower Pace change that
Aaron was unable to acknowledge it she
could see her old friend was getting
more tired sleeping longer his tail
really wagging as much as it used to but
by now that felt like Pancho's normal
behavior then again given how important
her dog was to her it's just as likely
she didn't want to accept the truth that
unfortunately nothing lasts forever he
was almost 15 in human years which by
all accounts is an impressive age for a
dog especially one of Pancho's size and
breed it was on a day that Aaron was out
working her morning job when it happened
the faithful adoring Jack Russell
Terrier who had spent his years being
nothing but loved and giving back only
more love in return curled up on Aaron's
bed the apartment was still Silent not a
found to be heard save for those last
tired few breaths laying there maybe the
dog wondered if he'd ever get to see his
friend again if she would make it back
from work in time he closed his little
brown eyes and peacefully drifted off
for one last sleep during the break
between her shifts after the end of the
one at her first job and before starting
her second Aaron had just enough time to
get home usually she had just had enough
time to eat and get herself ready for
the changeover then quickly check on
Pancho before having to dash back out
poking her head into the bedroom she saw
her dog laying right there on her bed
there was a Stillness to him that
instantly made her stomach drop his ears
didn't move when she called his name he
didn't react when she stroked his fur he
was gone and the moment she realized it
Aaron felt like her whole world had come
crashing down the loss of her oldest and
closest friend hurt almost as much as
losing her mom Aaron always felt that
the problem with funerals wasn't just
how sad they were or how it always
seemed to rain when she went to one
instead it was more that they could
never properly sum up just how much
someone truly meant nobody could ever
condense the year's worth of love and
memories into a burial and it was worse
when losing a pet there was no
procession no wake nobody else there
just her and Pancho saying goodbye a
final time eventually things got to be
too much the Heartbreak of Pancho's
death was another struggle in the
lifetime of lows that had all left their
lasting wounds on Aaron that coupled
with this stress of trying to carry on
with a busy life barely able to keep
herself afloat in either of her jobs had
pushed her to the edge of a breakdown
maybe that's what summoned it perhaps
something had sensed all of Aaron's
mental anguish and had come to seek her
out it might have been that her wishes
for something some little alleviation to
all the pain and stress were finally
being granted or maybe it was just a
gift left by her neighbor her the sun
had long since set when Aaron arrived
back at her apartment stepping over the
envelopes that littered her doormat a
few with words like overdue and Urgent
notice printed on them in red ink
passing through the hallway Aaron paused
as she always did hoping to hear the
gentle pattern of Paws against the floor
her therapist had dissuaded her from
doing that saying it would only make
moving on from losing Pancho worse she
didn't care she wanted her dog back and
opening the door to her bedroom it
seemed like someone had been listening
sat on her bed was a stuffed animal
right in the spot where she'd found her
little friend on that horrible day it
had been made to look like a dog
specifically resembling a Jack Russell
Terrier with brown patches over its
white fur the plushie was even wearing a
little rain poncho the side of it was
enough to cause Aaron to break down in
tears weeping in heavy sobs as she
dashed across the bedroom to hold it in
her arms hugging it tightly her tears
seeped into the soft her as she felt it
against her face she didn't even think
to question where it had even come from
all she wanted to do in that moment was
hold the stuffed animal close for the
first time in what felt like years a
feeling of relief washed over Aaron it
was as if everything was melting away
the stress of work and the toll of her
tiring shifts gone all the pain from
losing Cleo and Pancho dissipated too in
fact it felt like she now had her
beloved dog back no it was better than
that it was almost as though everything
about Pancho his energy his Spirit the
way he made her feel so calm and loved
was all distilled into this stuffed
animal and now it would never grow old
never age and die causing her more pain
Aaron gripped the soft toy tightly the
longer she held the hug for the more her
stress and sadness faded her face was
still wet with tears although her
sobbing had gradually become low gentle
Chuckles soon giving way to appeal of
uncontrollable laughter rising in volume
it was as though she had taken something
and the Very chemistry of her brain was
being altered but after so much hardship
it felt good to the point where she was
almost lightheaded laying down on the
floor of her bedroom arms locked around
the plushie that reminded her so much of
Poncho Aaron continued softly giggling
to herself her entire body relaxed so
much so that every part of her felt like
warm butter as if she was about to start
melting through the floorboards although
she didn't know it or probably wouldn't
have even cared her dopamine levels were
spiking flooding her with the bodily
hormone that relieves stress and makes a
person feel good in fact right now she
was feeling better than she ever had
every day that followed Aaron would come
home to our stuffed animal her Poncho
too as she'd like to think of it it
didn't bother her how childlike anyone
else might find it for a grown woman to
rely so heavily on a plushie for Comfort
at any rate it wasn't something she was
advertising to anyone else after every
shift at both of her jobs she'd race
back to her apartment right to Poncho
too and just sit there just basking in
the way it made her feel it was the most
all-encompassing sense of euphoria and
relief reducing her stress so much that
she felt like she was floating her body
lighter than air that feeling was all
that mattered to her some days she
wouldn't even eat Poncho 2 was more
important to her than food gradually she
started to become addicted to that
feeling having to wait until the end of
her work shifts to feel that Rush of
happy chemicals flood her brain was too
long of a delay she started to Crave it
while working unable to focus feeling
erratic and Restless without Poncho too
of course she couldn't risk bringing it
to work with her what if someone took it
or she dropped it her boss might see her
with a stuffed animal at her desk and
fire her on the spot or think that she
was absolutely crazy the only safe place
for her source of relief was at home but
Aaron knew she needed something to
bridge the gap while she was working the
only substitute that worked was taking a
photo of Pancho 2 on her phone then
blowing it up and printing off a copy
Aaron could carry it around portably
keeping it in her pocket and taking it
out to look at it every few minutes
while she worked the hit of positive
chemicals it gave her wasn't quite as
strong as getting to hold her stuffed
animal after all it was just a grainy
photo from her phone essentially acting
like a patch to tighter over until she
could get back home to the real thing
however it didn't take long for Aaron to
start taking Pancho with her anywhere
that wasn't work to the grocery store to
visit her mom and her dog and of course
to therapy I'm rather concerned about
this pattern of behavior Aaron's
psychotherapist Dr Lee stated when her
patient explained what had been
happening sitting across on the opposite
side of her office on a leather couch
Aaron had Poncho 2 pressed tightly
against her I don't care she side her
brain already Awash with hormones that
kept her calm I like how it makes me
feel so I don't care Aaron look at
yourself Dr Lee urged you aren't
properly dealing with your grief it
seems to me you're channeling all your
desire for positive emotion into this
stuffed animal Poncho two Aaron
corrected her without taking her eyes
off the soft brown and white dog and its
little cloak listen to me the therapist
insisted trying desperately to get
through to her Poncho you dog your real
dog is gone you lost him six months ago
and your mom Cleo she passed away too
you have to process and come to terms
with those things as sad as they might
make you feel that's how we move on but
what you're doing right now isn't
healthy Aaron it's becoming an obsession
Turning Away Aaron press Poncho 2 up
against her face I don't care she
repeated by now Aaron had become fully
dependent on Pancho 2 showing up late
for both jobs just so she could spend
longer feeling those endorphins and
hormones that hugging the stuffed
animals seem to bring it didn't take
long for her to start skipping entire
shifts for days at a time and canceling
any and all other plans just to sit at
home basking in the relief brought on by
her apparent Obsession her apartment
became a mess untidy piles of mail by
the front door the walls plastered with
hundreds of photos of her stuffed animal
fueling her Obsession her evening job
was the first to fire Aaron citing her
recent absences as the grounds for her
dismissal even then she still didn't
seem to care the fact she might not be
able to make rent barely registered
returning home after her other job
called her in to tell Aaron she would no
longer be working there either she
instantly looked around for Poncho too
but it was nowhere to be found all the
photos on the walls having faded Aaron
checked her phone all the original
copies of the pictures were gone too
instantly racked with fear so addicted
to the plushie that she could barely
function without it she began tearing
her apartment to shreds looking for it
she wrenched cupboards off their hinges
and tipped over her refrigerator
flipping her mattress Aaron sliced the
fabric open with a kitchen knife
searching high and low for Poncho too
but unable to find it anywhere she
became frantic erratic pulling her hair
out in a fit of uncontrollable despair
where had it gone had someone stolen it
Dr Lee the paranoia had already set in
convincing Aaron that her therapist must
have taken Poncho too she was the only
other person who knew about it and had
been so critical of her using it to make
herself feel better marching into Dr
Lee's office utterly enraged Beyond
Reason all Aaron could think about was
getting her stuffed animal back no
matter what she had to do the effect it
had on her was so powerful so potent and
addictive that living without it was
worth anything even another person's
life
little did Aaron realize as her hands
grew wetter coated with more of Dr Lee's
blood after every bludgeoning strike her
therapist had no idea where Pancho 2 was
in fact she had nothing to do with it
Vanishing in the first place it had
disappeared all on its own along with
all the photograph copies Aaron had
printed arriving somewhere miles away
scp-589 was ready to begin the whole
cycle again on its next victim it would
take on whatever shape it needed to
appease the desires of the very next
person to find it preying on their
vulnerability and making them totally
dependent on it that was what it did
everywhere it went leeching off people
that it could easily manipulate its
presence and interaction would calm
scp-589's victims helping to alleviate
their stress or make them feel better
about their deepest insecurities before
long these helpless victims would be
able to think of nothing else feeling as
if they were unable to live without
their ups fashion doll and every time
that was when scp-589 would make its
cruelest move it would vanish leaving
its prey in a state of intense
withdrawal with a calming influence of
scp-589 absent from their lives all of a
sudden the infected people would suffer
from a variety of potential
psychological symptoms manic depression
psychosis uncontrollable despair
Dementia or an errands case paranoia and
a heightened sense of aggression that
caused her to murder Dr Lee that was one
of the earliest in a Spate of similar
incidents that had been reported as
scp-589 traveled from town to town its
influence spread leaving entire
populations dead in its wake all the
while the stuffed animal fed on the
mental anguish that it caused its
victims making them pay the ultimate
price for their Obsession now go and
check out
scp-2295 the bear with a heart of
Patchwork and scp-6330 guard audience of
the innocent for more stuffed animal
related anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation